foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
my check
my check
see where the levels is at 2022
season finale
what's going on around we outside we're
here we're back
talk to y'all
without holy for cargos of the building
show for sure no questions Gerald Mack
yo G Bay Area stand up what's going on
oh hell oh hell the Lord's here you hear
me you know all that Lydia Master yeah
Halo with the Lords with fire happy born
day my brother added we had to throw it
up for him that was so much fun we hit
the legend the legendary scribe of the
we already know what it is brother you
know so good to see you in here great I
heard the World Cup is popping I see
it's going on right now Eric asked Kyle
IOP this is awesome yes yes yes we got
it done we got it done the contract
decided deals were done and he's he just
pulls up while I'm talking
we're doing Mike Jackson
I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying it you
came through with it with the directions
I can't I can't mess it with you listen
the boy is prop man the boy prom boys
professional okay professional I got you
know kind of trying to make sure I got
everything straight I'm doing good man
I'm talking to the people Park visual
what's up I'm Max what's going on
I'll see you Isaac Gentry what up Lord I
mean I need the links oh yeah
um UK lad I see you okay okay
[Music]
you the best
you know to try to get to it
[Music]
boy's so professional boy so probably
here before my co-host
my co-hosts this is how professionally I
follow directions
look it's it's the weekend
it's funny because I think about that
stuff a lot right which is like it's
people's time like this is people's time
that you've set for forbidness so I'm
like you know never never want to make
uh yeah mess it up on my end and I feels
bad the question hustling motivate I see
you brother I see you all right I just
sent you the link in a zoom chat let me
show you got on it no doubt you see the
people coming they're coming into the
conversation
they got their Sunday Best on I love it
I see you with the big church hat in the
back
how do you think the band gets paid
oh this show gonna be fired
oh my man black conflict X what's going
on power to the people for the movement
I see you that is the that is one of the
best names
[Music]
ever let's go that hustling motivated my
favorite show I love hustling motivation
I guess maybe you want to fight in front
of a boat David yeah
what's up brother good to see you Corey
Mosley what's going on
no doubt and I always butcher this man
is it because I'm not a
pecan pycon Fusion it's one of them
characters I'm badly
[Music]
[Music]
just want to talk to you people we got
my Med caught in the building we got
some fun and uh yeah we're gonna get the
rest of the realm in here also make sure
you say happy born day to my brother
Lord addict it was his birthday
yesterday I saw y'all in the Halo stream
it was a lot of fun so we will be back
talk to y'all in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social or my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold y'all
I ain't heard the boy and you ain't
gotta say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Voltron with and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot to get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
means that you are pulling up to the
iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing that real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social
knowing my city but I'm still by Coastal
I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot to get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
snapping and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless messaging people on AIM check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
and we are live iron Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it so we got that Focus
line y'all this is that standard this is
what we use right now kind of our
caffeine substitute and what we usually
do right now when we're gaming we don't
use coffee anymore we're utilizing this
Focus or deck number two you already
know it's my favorite right here the
energy line you already know birthday
cake one of my absolute favorites
completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta Adeline so you don't get the
Jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know Cog
lover is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advancedg.com calm use code iron Lord
on the checkout this is something I use
all the time got to support Advanced EG
great products if you want to get your
workout on even if you don't work out
you're just gaming you need that focus
and again the hydration line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lower
Cognito here iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental was an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies he's still
a mosquito you swear he ain't something
but really be civil you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke you
never still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
all right still a little level check
somebody say something right quick I
know how you doing up here there we go I
see the levels
[Laughter]
and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 285 the
final episode of 2022 y'all and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord's day I'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got spawn on me and the Lord's
raiding games to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who not
only represents one of the Premier
platforms to Spotlight Gamers of color
but whose passion for Tech Sports and
video games always radiates with the
utmost professionalism while still
maintaining his finger on the pulse of
the culture
introducing the founder and host of the
twitch YouTube and audio spawn on Me
podcast
the Lord of bringing Nuance back to the
internet
New York Spirit sports team loyalists
ping pong and it's still the leader of
the Paris can't cook movement
finally Love by way of Falling by way of
the boogie down and finally making his
debut into the realm of the Lord my man
Lord Khalif Adams have spawn on me how
he doing sir my liege my brother thank
you so much for having me it has been a
long time coming I am super excited to
be rocking with you and the rest of the
crew I am so hyped to be here that intro
I need to tattoo that on my bed like a
Tupac tattoo
whenever I walk into a room that's what
people see I need that in my life yes
it's the second Tupac reference you did
that's Tupac references it's true it's
true it's true I did come on the show
looking like an extra from above
to let my New York my New York love show
again as one Bronx brother to another
one we already know we have that every
day bro
fully represented right now so lovely
represented the Knicks are still in the
playoffs that was crazy right as of this
recording which is something I did not
think I would say in 2022 but the mix is
still in any playoff hunt same thing
with the Jets please Lord protect Jalen
brunson's feet please the armor of
protection on his toes and his ankles
we can continue to have wonderful times
in the basketball world but seriously
thank you so much for the intro and for
having me and and again it's been a long
time coming I'm very excited to be
rocking my child today likewise brother
long overdue huge fan of you obviously
you're a lord in your room it's only
right we gave you that proper
introduction and proper respect what
have you been playing it's lately what
games have you played oh man I've been
playing Vampire survivors has been my
jam which is a it's a wild game to be
like hey this 2D Sprite game that is
minimalistic and it's in its uh
aesthetic it's been keeping me up all
day it's like I'm out there feening like
it's New Jack City looking into the belt
bucket
just like yo I can't get out I can't get
out it's so good uh I was playing that
to like two o'clock in the morning
it's addictive for sure yeah because you
just have that continuous like I'd one
more run one more run that kind of vibe
um playing a ton of cod right now Call
of Duty is like in the bag right now
like I just finished the raid last night
yeah
the raid is really interesting it's um
it's one of those things where you can
see the influences from so many
different kinds of um encounters like
that it feels the the closest analog to
it would be like if you were to play one
of the destiny dungeons right
um it has that kind of vibe to it the
little bit of puzzle craft in it it's a
little bit of um you know busting people
in the face with the gun guns it's a
little bit of that it's a little bit of
you know uh the teamwork elements of it
are really really profound in in the
raid so so all of those pieces you can
tell are coming together and and it kind
of weaves some narrative through it
which is which is which is the thing I
was hoping for
um it's really really interesting I
think I think from a first kind of you
know foray into that space they're doing
well I think I I have more excitement
for what they're gonna do in the next
version of it to see where they kind of
like yourself so we got to break
protocol so we'll violated but we got it
we got it we gotta put light on it's
kind of funny
and they violated crazy that's amazing
we got chaplain two dollars in the chat
breaking news the Knicks
champion May Herb Williams find you in
the street and stuff on your shoes
oh but but it's a lot of good stuff in
the mix right now playing through that
high on life too that's been pretty
pretty fun too so a lot of stuff on the
table right now that's kind of being in
in the rotation so yeah man love to hear
it love to hear it and you already know
we're gonna get into this show that we
got normally have the Four Horsemen of
gaming original Lords of rum here at the
round table but we're waiting on our
birthday brother was that a wild night
salute the hair back attic it's coming
don't worry attic is coming he is um
yeah check pause
for that one oh he will be arriving he
will be arriving
he will be arriving to the podcast but
um
he's like yo I'm coming through don't
even worry about it cool cars here we
need to see you bro you know what I'm
saying but salute everybody that came
out for the birthday stream yeah
yesterday seeing Paul came through and
all that but you know he's still got our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer list for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Davis the
Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of the
iron bake my man Lord Sovereign how we
doing sir I'm good man I'm good I'm a
week away from a week of rest I'm happy
nice yes
I asked Lady stop I was like so what do
you want to do this weekend she was like
nothing
no traveling no nothing we usually do
Christmas morning like early at my
sister's house you know because but my
niece and nephew are big now we told
them like you know what yeah open your
gifts that are over there and and and
Theo Titi will be there later
you're not doing this early morning
stuff yeah early one yeah
until my wife but I you know adopt or
whatever and we start the process again
with small kids now we're not doing it
yeah
that's what all this busyness man have
you guys just played anything like like
Khalif man the only thing that they
could weasel its way in especially now
since it's on the phone as well it's
vampire survivors
it's like we got the little DLC they got
added to it oh man look a little dollar
fifty DLC but again for a game like
vampire survivors that's like DLC they
just released it a bunch of new items on
the news
that fast survivors on the on the steam
deck and also the phone on the phone I
recommend you you throw on that uh
backbone or whatever you have to do not
touch screen it it's nothing
it actually it compensates a little bit
for the movement so you could tell that
the the you know the uh the monsters
aren't as beasts they're not they're not
chasing you like that even when it gets
a little bit faster but it's it's not
the same feeling because you kind of do
feel like you start losing control I'm
like nah you know throw the backbone on
put it in horizontal mode and you're
good to go yeah besides that chipping
away at evil the evil West chipping away
at um Callisto protocol and God of War
as well Ragnarok just trying so
hopefully hopefully one of those will be
completed by the time we come back it's
crazy that that thing came out a long
time ago you know you know how I do it
you know
the backlog is crazy but that yeah
that's pretty much been it no doubt no
doubt and speaker show shout out to
Kathy I see some people in the chat I
can see foreign
welcome back sir I haven't seen you in a
minute happy holidays Jen's five dollars
Super Chat thank you sir appreciate it
slow mo say Cat Daddy
call them by his name
is a masterpiece Jane Cameron James
Cameron fire I yeah maybe that is the
one thing I will do is watch Avatar over
the uh yeah are you doing that right
he's not lying about that oh I I were
you interested I wasn't Avatar alone but
we'll figure it out if not we'll figure
it out no doubt no doubt shout out to
dreadpool I see you brother good to see
you in there no doubt and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer ooh the prophet of Xbox
Swami King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how we doing sir I'm
doing fantastic
um I didn't do the live stream last
night for combat talk with the King uh
because we gave y'all a ton of stuff
yesterday yes and I didn't want to
overlap on the channel and start taking
stuff away so it's like a numbers game
so
last night we had uh Frank Martin versus
uh Michelle Rivera okay now his name is
Michelle I was about to say there's no
clown over here he can fight he could
beat you up okay
but but the thing about it was those are
two unbeaten Fighters and in this day
and age uh to headline a pay-per-view
card with no belts on the line yeah uh
this was Errol Spence's uh first
promotional foray oh yeah
and he got uh Frank Martin to a
pay-per-view oh and he took the toughest
competitor that was out there which was
uh Rivera okay
um I'm not gonna lie talk to me Frank
showed out Frank remember when smoke
Gainer came on the scene and he looked
like that invitation Roy Jones
well this this guy looks like uh
imitation Earl with the work effort it's
a little man that got that yeah okay
and they do their thing um it was
something beautiful to see uh listen um
Michelle keep your head up uh
you was supposed to be circling to your
left you kept circling to your right to
his power hand and if I was able to yell
it to you I would have told you Circle
to your left and shoot right down the
middle and uh finish off with your hook
you didn't do any of that you should get
rid of your uh the coaches because that
was the biggest fight of your life last
night and you look like he wasn't
prepared yeah it was just he had the
tools he didn't have the the people the
related information to him so no
Direction but other than that you've
been playing the kid was uh you know so
I forgot to tell you that he was playing
Halo yesterday I apologize
wow
today is the launch for somebody else
that's how Game Pass works okay that's
how we do it that's how Game Pass work
every day is a new day okay um let's
play that vampire Survivor high on life
oh talk to me I'm a huge Rick and Morty
dude oh
yo I didn't I thought they was going to
run out of things to say after the the
first 10 minutes this dude got something
new to say to hold him I know the game I
know the disc is just full with his him
talking just just his vocals there and
then the knife when you get the knife
the knife is homicidal
I do not recommend this game for any
child
at all at all at all I banned my son
from playing
because in the beginning of the game I
don't even know how this game passed
anything I'll be honest with you I'll be
real with you we can speak to [ __ ] I
interviewed the desk
yeah yeah don't they crazy he out of
control in the beginning of the game
they partake in party favors you know
and you know as adults we know what
party favors are
um
you're not supposed to do that it's
different kind of power okay
so I'm like oh hell no meat Burger
immediately I told my son you you are
forbidden from this game is it but daddy
is so colorful nope not for the kids so
Rick and Morty it's it's dope fortnite
got this thing called my hero there now
just like they did the Dragon Ball Z
thing they did the my hero thing and I'm
learning about the characters but they
implementation of of of of of other like
John was like anime or whatever date is
seamless these dudes have they post on
on the populace and that game is never
gonna stop
um I was trying to get y'all to play
yesterday bro shout out to y'all playing
demio and everything else shout out to
everybody that came for the community
stream and y'all do know this is our
last show for the rest of the year so uh
give spawn all your attention for show
for sure you already know and of course
we have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading that real
into the Roman IOP not tell you what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to my brother Mr Maddie plays
shout out to finally do we have some
cool episodes this week uh first one
kind of went on whole law kind of
breaking down the latest to The Saga of
the Activision Blizzard cake
who did what who signed who what's going
on how's it going to move forward in
court concessions no concessions all
that good fun talk that I know y'all
love to hear is there from a you know
from a legal mind you know so we got
some clarity there shout out to Maddie
and our main show um we had talking
about kind of Xbox's potential 2023 the
room would show that may be happening or
not happening well you know expectations
there shout out to my um Thai Guy Travis
City boxes for the last word talking
their Destiny season of the serif and we
have my man song lab on really I like
this cat young cat you know really knows
the lore of Destiny he's like you know
what he's like young bite like young
Vice like yo this dude talks and you can
just you can see the words you know
coming off the page so salute to him we
went hard on that and um yeah as far as
me
um midnight Sun's going hard bro I'm
going hard midnight Suns I'm in the mix
I'm playing the combat I'm getting
better complex you know what's happening
now so I'm like this game is way deeper
than I thought it was I thought it was
just simplistic on the card level now
we're getting mods now the research
layer and the base layer is just as deep
as not more deep than the card game so
I'm starting to notice stuff there that
the stuff is ramping up the the classic
faraxis hardcore x-com tropes are
kicking in and I love it you know what
I'm saying so it's like dude yes I'm
like I know how this goes like do your
side missions do your other stuff
because when the game ramps up you
better be ready you ready yeah so I've
got my synergies I got my heroes that I
like got Wolverine lock now got Catholic
he's got like a little defensive flow
with the shield and all that torn enemy
like it's it's really good the sad part
is is that I know some people are not
gonna like the tender portion of the
game so people are just not gonna get
into that click like see if we're gonna
go I'm gonna go in the book club with
blade I'm we'll go and sit by the pool
with Miss Marvel like I know some people
not gonna be about that you know what
I'm saying but other than that give it a
chance um shout out to attic that pulled
up we did demio last night oh shout out
to you sir what's up with your Flex that
you had to put on people with your
screens uh shot that you put up with
your your argument the reality yeah the
only one with it right they're the only
one that could do this
everybody else playing at you know 480p
I had to represent the whole team for a
minute
yeah you know he's doing on that Pro The
Meta Quest Pro and of course uh we had
the birthday boy in there and we was
rocking which we just arrived now and um
we was rocking that uh new on dungeon
man reign of Madness is a mate shout out
the resolution yeah I did it again yo
I'm telling you right now who I know
people that hate VR that's fine PC guys
get on it PlayStation guys y'all better
support this girl yo but I'm coming for
y'all cause this one what are you
talking about relax your mouth
the time with you for being messy PS5
the psvr VR2 is going to be on the
platform I'm telling you right now this
is one of the best turn based games one
of the best new turn based games
Cooperative doesn't I'm telling you and
they have legit boss mechanics that are
better than your favorite games wow it
is that that voice got we got to the
final dungeon that boss got us up out of
yo can keep playing he playing demio in
demio against you he moving the pieces
or I'm like oh about like the the
outside thought process of how they
created this and how tough it is is this
is a seasoned veteran kind of dungeon
thing so shout out to attic shout out to
um citizen shout out to um Volcan we
tried it we got smacked we'll be back
we'll be back and then um last thing is
I started uh Final Fantasy 7 Crisis Core
on Xbox so just messing with that and uh
Lord Adam everyone didn't come out yet
the Remake
we got the prequel biscuits
[Laughter]
was so much fun and uh yeah talk to the
people to enjoy yourself anything else
you did real quick
yeah the um
the Halo stream was definitely a huge
success I I spent like like must have
been two two and a half hours looking in
that stuff because I wanted to make sure
that we got like some of the best
content that was available and it's just
it's just a fun time man it's a fun time
it's a shame the game didn't launch like
this yes because I felt I could be a
completely different story uh but you
know hopefully
they'll be able to capitalize on it in
some way no doubt no doubt yeah new new
game pass subscribers
gotta move forward because I gotta
respect uh lokai's time and we do got to
pay the bills a little bit so solve um I
got some scribes to do unless the super
chat's a small little potassium smart
can do that right now this is quick hold
on a second so we have we have Donald
Taco happy belated birthday Lord addict
then we have you know I got soul five
dollar Super Chat I see Lord salt and
pepper through the Just For Men in the
bushes
that look bro oh man yo yo listen my
wife told me she said you look sexy as
hell I said well you know what's gonna
happen right
well Xbox release the hounds in
parentheses games since the FTC is
tripping I don't know they may they may
hold on to the hounds we'll see and we
have Hollywood rules ten dollars we chat
just want to wish my NYC video game
cousins a great show thank you sir thank
you brother King and United keep up the
movie talk IOP is the best video game
podcast Bar None happy holidays Brothers
to you and your families to you as well
thank you brother what's up what's up
technically an IOP that's that's r r
uh yeah
we'll be doing the spoiler cast on or
Avatar this Tuesday and we got some DC
stuff to talk about as well so I
definitely be looking forward to that
it's gonna be an uh interesting
interesting conversation because I I
watched it I watched it uh Saturday no
doubt no doubt no Friday Friday yeah
shout out to wilmy gaming behind the box
he said attic I'm sending you some Croc
gloves for your birthday
wow they make frog gloves as well
he's trolling him I'm surprised King
doesn't have someone
speaking of course gloves are basically
a fishnet gloves
we're gonna Crush
you messing it up for the borrow
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
first of all shout out to the entire
team man it's been a phenomenal year the
competition for this award is always
Fierce man and sometimes I'm only
separated by like about one vote so I
want to shout out to the best riders in
the game up and coming Lords of
gaming.net but it's time to celebrate a
specific scribe who went Above and
Beyond in the month of December the boy
killed it he dominates with engagement
with his articles he's got a passion for
Pokemon battle he's got a passion for um
actually demio VR and VR to space and
then also um so really the provoking
pieces on um Ukrainian devs making video
games during time of War so that was
really informative and uh yeah we
proudly present the latest Lord dizzy
log net scribe of the month Lord Chris
Jones AKA see you knit one two three one
two three congratulations now he
couldn't make it but he did drop a video
for us so we're gonna we're gonna play
that video for the brother you know what
I'm saying give me one second let's set
him up right now
what's going on everybody it's Chris
Jones your boy AKA c unit one two three
one two three the Michael Jordan the
lognet squeaking in a union expert and
let me just say about all them other
news sites I don't care about them throw
them in the bushes
let me be clear
I'm implying lognet lordsagaming.net
that is the site you need to get all of
your gaming and media news from we are
doing big things over there and the
thing about us is we don't get paid
we're all doing it just for the love of
gaming and the love of writing so you
know it's honest you know it's from the
heart and a big shout out to uh the
people that chose me for a scribe of the
month for December it's a humbling honor
uh the iron Lords Cog SOB attic King
pillars of positivity within the gaming
community
uh four people that make it a worth the
time and effort that each of us put into
uh getting these articles out for you
guys
so once again I thank you for this
opportunity to be your scribe of the
month and I
will be back again
salute
full salute to my broke see you today
Chris Jones again fantastic month of
December man he absolutely killed it
pleasure to have him in the realm and
then of course we do have a second award
for lawsagaming.net and this is this is
different closed out the year pretty
kind of prestigious award kind of person
that's like the pillar of consistency
and quality throughout the year
multi-talented scribe y'all he's got
quality articles he represents the fgc
the fighting game Community I love his
Recaps he has detailed raid walkthroughs
if you people were into Destiny and he's
also talented enough to do a video
series with Lord King that Weekly Lords
minute telling you everything that's
going on the entertainment pop culture
superhero movies whatever my boy got you
he's that guy so we proudly present the
2022 winner of the Lord dizzy lognet
scribe of the year
to Lord Ty Swinson AKA Prince delos
congratulations brother speak speak
where you at you're supposed to pull up
hopefully he pulls up man it'll be great
to see him because he said he was going
to try it he said he's coming damn it
brother you're late for yours
you're late for your award you said he
coming but look man hopefully I give him
a minute but y'all look tired probably
you've been absolutely killing it the
quality the consistency you know got a
chance to meet him actually in real life
I was at gcx in Orlando and he pulled up
we had a great time man salute to you
man actually pillar in the site and we
love to see it it was very again this
award is very contentious so just be
clear a lot of people in the running
don't blow body getting their feelings
we trust me it's the base with the
editors you know what I'm saying kind of
thing but hopefully he comes in and then
I'll do my final award all right now
hopefully I can get Ty his uh his
flowers when he comes in and the final
award and this is kind of something that
again rest in peace Lord dizzy actually
not to get his somber but actually
watched for the first time you're not
even watched the um farewell we did for
them you never watched it yeah I
couldn't watch it I couldn't after we
did it was my first time I want the
tears is Flowing bro yeah he hit me
right back so um this is something when
we created launch gaming.net you know
wanted to be teachers and nurturers I
mean them because I'm not a fantastic
writer these are like he was this was
his vision you know I'm saying to and I
say look I'm gonna do that but um yeah
we want to give proper credit to the
unsung heroes you know the the editorial
staff that's the lifeblood of the site
you know this editor um exemplifies kind
of what being a teacher and a journalist
is supposed to look like in my opinion
calm demeanor pure gamer Fair assessment
of talent you know and um one of the
anchors that what we do at
lawsagaming.net so proudly want to
present the winner of the Lord Disney
editor of the month to my man Lord
Mahmoud gafar AKA Lord wait wait I know
you was in here earlier I know you said
you could have made you made the family
I know but we got to give you your
flower is salute to you you are the
lifeblood of the sight great guy to work
with really cool salute to him I see
everybody throwing it throw the Disney's
up in the chat because this award was
inspired by him my boo was there for
dizzy everybody said shout out y'all
still got yeah shout out to you brother
I see you um gaming behind the box I see
you brother yeah you did you and the
team did so much for dizzy and uh yeah I
just want to salute him I'm ty here good
tired I need to speak quick for your
award subscribe and describe it again
talk to me Brother start your camera
what's going on with Florida today man
it's Florida messing up yeah
you're having difficulty I know he tried
I know he tried man got snatched by a
gator yeah
all right salute salute that's what I
look there we go there we go
that's my guy that's my guy waiting for
him to kick it and he warming up he
cooking Ty what's up brother
oh there we go there's the Scribe of the
Year let's go
speech well uh first off like I said in
our Discord I was
um a little surprised to have won this
award I'm very humbled to have done so I
wanted to aim to work hard for this
award at the beginning of the year
something that I subscribed to
um seeing all the great content the site
uh puts out and the wonderful people we
have on the team I wanted to uh live up
to that and to make everyone proud and
make myself proud and see how much I
could really push in 2022.
um as the holiday season kicked in in my
primary job kind of took over my life
um it was hard to keep getting content
out as much as I wanted to for the site
but I still pushed through and tried my
best
um and I just appreciate
um all the support and guidance from the
team from the editors from ucog and all
the leadership and
um yeah once again uh being at Lords of
gaming is great it's a great experience
great atmosphere knowing Lords minutes
with King my bread and butter my goat
it's great it's something I look forward
to whenever we get around to doing it so
no doubt I'm just happy to be here
congratulations man again you were
pulling inside we love what you do the
passion is evident I was telling
everybody I got it I was blessed to get
a chance to finally meet you in person
and obviously a GCF yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying let's go I got to get my
man a couple you know a couple drinks
behind you know what I'm saying chill
out and that was cool man salute you
brother you well deserved you're
relaxing to the team and again very
contentious of what everyone is in the
mix but like I said it could go a couple
ways but we got to celebrate the guys
that that make us look good and you're
one of those guys so salute to you
brother enjoy your day you know what I
mean and uh yeah speak to them oh
actually I'm sorry I was waiting on an
answer because I didn't know the answer
so the answer is you get a game sir so
you just let me know what that is okay
okay yeah no doubt no doubt let me know
what that is and I'll get that right to
you all right thank you so much and I
hope to see you all at E3 next year oh
you know what's going down bro you know
what's going down brother enjoy your
Sunday good to see you brother flip
scrubs of the Year scrubs of the bluff
we are all caught up in the business we
are good to solve last Super chest and
then we got a very patient guest yes we
do so the last Super Chat that we have
no no is this hard Gates
happy holidays Huggy once again coming
through for the community we got some
codes for Need for Speed on Unbound evil
West wow we have the Quarry we have
Witcher 3. shout out to Heart Geet for
doing this every week he does this for
for the for the community shout out to
you sir and congrats to you guys that uh
managed to get the codes yeah if you got
the codes well I got all of the heart
King has been working on his hands feed
together
all right so we all good we're good all
right now we got them paying the bills
doing everything we're supposed to be
doing we gotta switch off focus to our
patient guests uh Lord Khalif man his
video game system history his journey
into blogging content operation and of
course what led him to host in one of
the most respected platforms that spawn
on Me podcast so Lord Kyle let's start
from the very beginning what were some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming first of
all I do love Festa charger shared
across your community that is so dope I
just love that apart as a party show as
a person who watches and listens to the
show a lot it is uh it is always
wonderful to see how much you all love
love on your on your crew in that way I
love that
um I'm old so all my consoles have wood
paneling on oh nice let's go let's go
let's go
the first console I ever had was a Atari
2600 yes and then 2600 went into the
valley Astro cave in the valley
astrocade went into the Vex tracks
the person that had a veterans like me
let's go brother salute brother yo so
all right um for people that don't know
what a vetrex is it's a self-contained
console with a television right all you
had to do is just find an outlet you
just plug it into the wall and the
controller was connected to the actual
uh the console which is a television
very small I think it was like 13 inches
because it was more uh like rectangular
but kind of vertically rectangular it
wasn't like 16 by nine it wasn't in that
horizontal performance yeah
and um that thing it came with a
built-in game and
um the asteroids
yeah yeah and then you you put the
cartridges in yeah I'm not gonna and
then you put the overlay over the front
oh this is so great speaking to somebody
that had that console because when I say
it people look at me with two different
heads oh my God what is your experience
with it like how did you come across it
because I came across about mistake I
think it was a mistake too I think my
grandmother thought she was buying one
thing and bought me that
funny because so so the wild thing is
I've been trying to track these things
down over the past couple years but
they've been extremely expensive you go
to conventions and they're like 700 800
I finally this year got both of them
back so I got one extra Cade and they're
over in the other room they're in like a
box somewhere uh but the vectrex was
really dope because of that cartridge
and overlay system because you know we
have UI and ux in in games now but
they're they're hard-coded into the
games this was dope because it was like
we had a blank slate and every game was
dictated by the overlay that you put on
top of it plus the cartridge yeah and it
was such an interesting space because it
was it was
vector graphics way before vector
graphics were a real thing yeah
um and it was just so cool because it
was like everything was self-contained
within this one unit uh and it was that
one moment where it's like I remember
very vividly my grandma
being like because I think I was moving
out or something like that and she threw
that she threw it away and I was like oh
no wow you did it in the most she did it
in the most black grandma ways
where she was like imma throw this away
but I'm not even just gonna throw it on
the curb I'm gonna cut the cables out
the joint so nobody else no wow like one
of those joints she's just following the
rules of recycling you know she was
recycling because she was petty she was
like nobody's using it I spent my money
on this nobody else
but that's that thing it's like yo cut
the cable or something but it was such a
like um in my formative Years of Gaming
right because I've been gaming since I
was three yeah uh I'll turn 45 next year
one of those things where you you have a
level of reverence for the space and you
know having seen all these games over
the past 30 40 years years of Our Lives
you have a appreciation for where we are
now so like when people are just like
this game is whack or these Graphics are
bad or this is a thing I'm like fam we
had two lines on the screen to go up and
down talk to them
we have stuff that didn't have faces on
like you like like King was talking
about where king with a high on life of
like how much how much dialogue went
into high on life right in in the voice
lines there were no voice lines there
was no voice yes good point you've seen
so many dope things in such a short
amount of time in the video game Space
you really just have to like give it
give it love so then you know go past
those layers of it then you get into the
NES the the Genesis and all and all
those kinds of the ones that we usually
talk about but I think it was even
cooler to have stuff that was even that
old yes so you needed an RF switch to
turn it on to you yes
you know what I mean like you had like
you had to borrow time from your parents
to be like okay can I borrow the TV
depending upon what the way your house
was situated if you had the top TV or
the bottom TV no bro this is real that's
my biggest thing about getting tricks
yeah you didn't have to bother anybody
right yes because being in the corner by
yourself and the speakers on it was
really good did you I'm a question did
you ever get ColecoVision because I'm
one of those uh gaming junkies so I I've
done
Omega everything all the way through
like Atari 2600 5200 and 72 7 800. I did
all of that stuff all the way through
did you do coleco Vision because I
thought coleco Vision like was ahead of
his time when I got it ColecoVision was
one of those really weird uh spaces
because you can see the jump from the
Bally Astro cage directly to what the
coleco vision was trying to do so like
the valley astrocade the controller
looked like a trigger right yes but it
had a joystick on the top of it was the
way you had your analog kind of movement
but it was only it was only in eight
directions it didn't have full
articulation so it was one of those
interesting things because you move from
the Atari which had its you know classic
joystick then you move over to the Bali
ashrocade that had a kind of hybrid of
what the the
Atari was trying to do and collegial
vision was more of a dial-based yeah
with some numbers on it so it was such
an interesting space to see and also
like the valley house because you can
spin the dial too it was like
articulated but you could spin it down
too so it was an interesting kind of you
see that the the angles of where gaming
was moving from an input perspective
and how that automatically changed the
way games were being kind of pushed out
into the world but ColecoVision was very
very special like people don't
understand how how talk to them while
Calico Vision was in the pantheon of
video game Lineage because it never
really got the love that it was supposed
to get because it was this weird
sandwich in between those two bigger
consoles but it had a space where like
companies like jalico oh got to got to
nail their space right they made a lot
of games for that
um another one I think that was really
kind of um that didn't get the love that
it deserved was the 3DO 3DS
nah we talking let's go let's go Romeo
was one of those consoles that never
really got love and and that was one of
the the ones that
absolutely should have gotten a whole
bunch of low because again like you know
we're we're of the age where the arcade
scene was
was Paramount that was like where you
went to go get comp yes right as a big
fighting game fan you know that's where
you went to go get it in right
um and to have some of that kind of come
home with you felt really good like Neo
Geo was one that was just like in that
space yeah it was too expensive but it
was you know it was it was ahead of its
time too because that was the bridge
between the home and the arcade same
thing yep same Hardware you know what I
mean it was literally the same Hardware
that you can get take your take your
card take your save from your home yeah
they had this was not in the arcade
everybody
because we on our way home from school
we'd stop in there and they'd have the
demo plan so we play baseball Stars we
play magician Lord and the guy would
always be like are you gonna buy this no
devil yo I remember dudes knew what my
wallet looked like when I went down to
Elizabeth Street and I took my memory
card fatal Fury and then my name came up
yeah
lacks but it was such a good time man
like I feel like I think the again the
beauty of where we are are in terms of
life and in terms of our hobby that we
really enjoy is that we are we have all
of this information that we've seen
across all of these years that have
influenced the way we think about games
the way that we appreciate games and I
think to a certain extent like the the
generations that will come up after us
they don't have that layer of
appreciation of reference for us
um in that way it's a different level of
it now because everything is is instant
right we never had instant we had to
wait for stuff we had to wait you're
right for money and yeah we had to wait
for time right like you know borrowing
the internet for video games I want to
interrupt you for a second because yeah
it's a waiting part you talk about is so
key and then it's actually making me
remember because you said like you said
waiting you go to the arcade you may see
something really great because that was
kind of the next gen step right but the
consoles weren't caught up yet so you
had to wait sometimes for the that poor
a wait for it to come through the other
thing that you mentioned is really
resonates with me is the fact that when
you took it back to the RF switch right
when you gamed you had to take other
people off the TV that was normally
there to watch TV so it also became like
the parents if you didn't have like
understanding parents who really didn't
get it like they were like no you like
you're you're taking away big back TV
time right you know they come back to TV
like a furniture
and all that with the wood finish and
all that but the thing is you had to
literally say okay I need I want to play
games move that R switch and now you're
dominating the TV and if there's one TV
the house was like no one else is going
to be able to watch anything so I
thought that was very key what you said
about about that answer but continue to
continue so you take me yes I mean that
was the the impetus for like kids
getting TVs in their rooms too yeah that
was like a part of that conversation of
all that stuff so my game England news
goes way way back for for many many
years so it's it's always one of those
things that when I see where we're where
we are now and I hear people complain
I'm like you really just don't
understand how good you have it yes yeah
absolutely because it's very rare that
we get people that's uh that actually
were collectors that actually was part
of the culture all the way through right
yeah yeah so and I know you said you
said time
uh how did you get your E3 news
oh man I was I when I would get E3 news
through egm
um
yes uh oneup.com and oneup.com was was
my Premier site to go to okay
um and then like Game Pro game pro like
Game Pro Mag was my journey with my
homie Sushi X and those cats right it
was like all of those places where it
was all at our go-to
was the twenty dollar tree
VHS tape oh yeah it was like it was like
a year late yeah because we were getting
six months after the fact
we get it and I remember seeing uh
Nintendo 64. that's what it was called
the ultra 64. Ultra 64. and they had the
Final Fantasy you know whatever demo
they showed on the screen
what you see everybody's stuff is
instant right now our stuff was
completely delayed so we didn't know
what a console name was truly
until probably six months after the fact
it was already deciding about the ship
but you brought up that time and time is
definitely for Real uh and we have to
make the adjustments these kids don't
have to make the adjustments we do yeah
I mean I think that's the beauty of it
too is like the the space that we occupy
right now like people will talk about
the the negative aspects of Gaming all
the time but what I tell people is like
we're in The Best Time Ever technology
technology wise
there is nothing that you for the most
part if you have means and again like
this is a coming from a privileged
conversation at a point right right of a
person who has some money in your job
and stuff and blah
but like for the most part if you are in
a space where you can have internet
access
and you have a console
or you have a mobile phone because you
know over in the East the mobile the
mobile gaming area is is so much bigger
than what it is here in the west wow you
have access to anything you want at this
point knowledge information
Entertainment Games I remember what it
was like to go to the library
it's a go pull you know books and movies
and stuff out I remember what it was
like when I needed to go get information
to go through a book called an
encyclopedia
that my mama said God knows how much
money y'all shout out to Britannica
did you have the salesman come to your
house yes yes yes yes and my mother was
like yo get out and then we got we got
the wrong
encyclopedias that had information that
was wrong and old oh no you got the
misprint yo because it was some over
some all other drink because it was like
my grandma I love my grandma like my
grandmother saved me from a lot of
things she gave me gaming she's the
person who gave me gaming as a thing uh
but she was cheap in some ways and that
cheapness would wind up kind of moving
over to some ACT to some aspects like I
wanted turntables one year and I was
like yo can I get some twelves she got
me like she got me like a regular
turntable oh no
money and then when I learned how much
money she made out she died you know
bless her soul I was like wow you really
did spend a grip of money just to just
for the hope of me having a hobby or a
thing to do but all that to say again is
like we are in some fantastic times I
think the gaming industry and the space
that we occupy right now is just
brilliant because you can literally do
anything you want at any time if you
have the means to do it absolutely no
tremendous man I love sorry you're gonna
say something no no no okay yeah no it's
tremendous uh Insight because again yeah
we we understand you know how much
better it is now and I think we have an
appreciation as ogs you know whereas
like and I think you said I watched the
show with you one time I think you said
it where it's like you know a lot of
times you see social media and
everyone's bad all the time all the time
all the time and it's like fam you don't
enjoy enough like how come you can't
post something into something you
playing that you like it and I think for
us though we have a different
perspective because we know what it came
from and it's like yo it is crazy like
it's really pop and how advanced things
are how instantaneous things are you
know what I mean and even the
transparency on information and how
quickly you can you can digest it so I
loved it loved you said that aspect so
I'm gonna assume you pretty much after
you know with from every console through
it was there any gaps like when you got
to let's say for example you know we did
16-bit air and all that stuff but like
was there any was there any consoles
that you didn't have that you wish you
had I wanted to ask you that I wanted a
turbo graphics 16. and I never got one
because I wanted box Adventure because
it reminded me to do down the block who
had a big forehead
dogs calling that boy punk
you were like yo he was Naruto running
before Naruto running
it was so heavy
foreign
16 was a drink that I never had and
really really wanted I did run a Neo Geo
because ape man was really dope and
again you had that conversation about
like what the you know the arcade space
was in comparison to that
um I never had natari links
I had legs I was a big licks fan I
wanted the links real bad and I missed a
lot of Nintendo stuff because Nintendo
stuff really wasn't in my in my in my
space except for
uh the NES and then Super Nintendo I
kind of skipped a lot of the Wii U stuff
and yeah you did good brother you did
good you did good it wasn't my jam yeah
you did good you did good yeah yeah yeah
so I still have a little bit
I can walk
I appreciate your services
because I was not rocking during that
period yeah it was it was a little bit
rough but like those are the major ones
that I remember missing
um in an arcade space died and then
consoles kind of came together and now
I think PlayStation killed the arcade
really oh okay break it down to be
honest with you because
um the 3D Graphics I mean because it it
became a thing of money right it became
a thing of yeah well I'm gonna go over
there and spend all this money in the
arcade because arcade machines started
going up in prices like and became
larger and larger like Daytona uh uh
afterburn uh stuff like that and hang on
you you you're just jumping into giant
machines because we would go to the
bowling alley on 161st Street oh yeah oh
yeah PlayStation came out 3D graphics
the audio was crazy
I don't have to do this no more like
when Ridge Racer looked like Ridge Racer
exactly in the arcade yeah in the house
yeah I got to go yeah I came from when
battle arena told she didn't okay that
game keep coming up that game was like
life-changing because I was like yo this
is in 3D 3D movement like what yes yes
that's a good point King about how that
kind of corresponded with the because
Sega was doing a lot of big things in
the arcade space for a long time and
then real quick
Nintendo uh delegation wants you to come
to the front of the conversation I don't
know if I can they they said how are we
going to have a history and you didn't
mention not much Nintendo do you have
anything to say for yourself like look
here's the thing that I loved about
Nintendo when I played Nintendo way back
in the day one of the things that like
captivated my mind and got thrown under
the bus were the light gun because it
didn't get enough love gyro might got no
low in terms of the stuff that they made
I'll even here's the thing to satiate
all the Nintendo fans I'll give you I'll
give you a piece of let's go Nintendo
lore that you might not have known this
tells you how dope I am let's go you
know that Nintendo made a loom
for the NES
you could make a sweater with your NES
so there you go that tells you that I
know some Nintendo stuff in the
background what was this around the
Power Pad and the glove area what was
this way early videos they had they had
they had a cartridge that was literally
one that you put in your NES okay and
you would Stitch you would make
stitching patterns and it was connected
to a loom what that you could purchase
do you remember the name it was wild it
was crazy so I saw I saw it at the Retro
convention here yes they pulled it out
because Nintendo was in a lot of
different stuff they were in a lot of
different things that wasn't just gaming
yes when they first started so it was a
multi you know kind of angled company
and then they saw the the growth of the
NES they was into cards yup yeah I'm
sure they did yeah so Nintendo Nintendo
makes the reason I like Nintendo is
because they make a lot of wild stuff
that nobody else would make but they
also play too much into Nostalgia and
then buy buy bite your balls oh yeah
yeah but your wallet yeah with that kind
of stuff no cardboard
like that thing that we did three times
again we're gonna give it to you again
wait no you don't like it no man
tremendous man history and then again
I'm assuming from back then since then
you know since the Next Generation
consoles you've been pretty much
consistent with everything still like
going forward let's say for example you
get to Xbox and PlayStation and those
Generations did you just kind of was all
the way in at that point yeah yeah yeah
like I I've kept up like I got all the
stuff they're underneath the table right
now I just had to move stuff but like
you know all those things now have just
been a part of the ecosystem like I'm
playing
stuff that like I have every PlayStation
now at this point every Xbox at this
point I'm playing stuff like I have a
play date now if you ever see if you
ever heard one of those yep you know
there's a lot it's a lot of stuff now
that comes across my table that I'm just
like oh this is really cool because now
we get a chance to again like experience
new versions of stuff that we had before
or new twists on things that we that we
see I'm way more excited for the future
than I think a lot of people are I think
a lot of folks are still kind of like
stuck in that like we need things to be
very you know kind of
manufactured in a certain way and feel a
certain way I'm like yo I don't need a
disc ever again
I I don't need like I don't need a
console anymore if we had if we had you
know the kind of infinite internet
infrastructure like they do in the East
throw all that joint through my TV if
there's no latency and I'm good you
better be careful I'm like just give me
a controller and leave me alone yeah
that's it at this point like run all
that stuff through do whatever you need
to run it through because all these all
these pieces of of gear and kit they're
great yeah but it leans into all the
weird fanboyism that we that we always
see yeah people talking about Hardware
they know gosh
everybody's an engineer you know six
months before the concert engineer like
everybody know where Ray tracing is I
see Ray tracing is right there yo him
and his cousin him and his cousin Milton
but it was funny because like I've
worked in a couple of different places
now in my nine to five career that are
gaming related or at least Hardware
related and I remember when the
conversations around Ray tracing were
popping up and a lot of other stuff and
I was working at Intel at that point uh
in their gaming Division and just seeing
the amounts in like waterfall of wrong
that people were just getting online and
they were like yo all these teraflops I
mean this game is going to be better
than that yo that yo yo that's crazy how
FX AAA is going to be up on natural and
I was like you like you just thought you
said TSA
bro you gave us like so and I was like
y'all don't know what y'all talking
about I'm Gonna Let You rock yo so true
go ahead you say what you got to say
especially I remember when the Xbox
whatever came out hey kid you gonna
laugh it's all people would talk about
es Ram the as RAM the secret song The
Secret Sauce
and what it was going to do and I'm like
bad like they were blog posts and
certain individuals that created
personas about tech and I'm just like
man what's going on baby I'm sorry I
interrupted he was about to say
something earlier
is my camera on yes you look wonderful
I've been messing up all day yeah I
didn't even collect nothing it just
randomly turned back on I don't know I
think the adapter I have is going out I
don't know now everything's good
everything yeah I don't think no matter
what you do you're gonna get rid of the
car they'll argue about the controllers
the service you use it the TVs you're on
it it's gonna be a battery again about
fast food joints like
my favorite conversation I saw was
somebody came out and was like yo son yo
if you just put on Cinema mode on your
TV you're gonna have the best experience
when you play games as low as the
latency
everything else
what's happening yeah so I go for like
solve is such a purist like remember
when TVs came out with that what was it
like that soap opera kind of effects
off hates it right so Ricky was like oh
my we used to call it yo it's real it is
in the Box we're like oh my God it's 60
frames is moving like it's real life
King got after we went to see Avatar
right King went and got the 3D TV he got
the 3D TV with like eight glasses oh
like he's like yeah I gotta come over to
see it right so we Cog and I go over
right so we sit down and he's showing us
what is the Charlize Theron movie
um uh what the heck on flux
right so he immediately throws on the
soap opera effect
Charlie's is in the living room with us
this is this she's right here she's
right here and Cog is like oh man yeah
awesome and I'm like you know but you
can't be disrespected
but King knows though King knows I was
awesome that's awesome we leave right
but we outside coconut cog's like yo man
that look crazy it's like it's not
supposed to
another story because he got me back oh
yeah this goes back to the high scan
not the high skin TV I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna do them now
do my brother like that television right
I have went to Best Buy for a lunch
break I was working delivering auto
glass right and I go to go to the
bathroom inside Best Buy I pull up
minding my business and I walk in
but it looked like real life I say yo I
said what's that he said Samsung Samsung
9 and whatever the hell I'm like uh okay
um how much is it he told me the price
I said give me it
I come home from work with a TV
my girl at the time was like what the
hell are you doing he said no it's real
life in the Box go go I can't front if
you ever want to disappear somebody talk
to me you take a take a brother through
the Costco aisle in the TV section there
you go they might they might wind up
gone you just never see them again
[Laughter]
I don't remember
that's all good it's all good but uh
yeah we talked about the game and we got
a chance that [ __ ] you know don't talk
about content creation you know and um
the podcast again you know kind of
turning like a hobby into something
right so I wanted to get you know your
perspective there like how did that
passion start and thinking about like
getting into the space
I mean I was I was working a a job I was
working at help desk job back home in
New York so I was working at one of the
municipal unions back home all right and
you know I I just didn't feel smart I
was tired of telling tired of telling
folks to how to use mice and keyboards
all day and I'm looking at me like yo is
that Cinema mode I'm like no it's not
Cinema mode
uh and I was like look I've always
wanted I've Loved video games forever
it's been a part of my life since I've
can remember
um and wanted to try to figure out a way
to do something I was like I can kind of
write I'm not you know classically
trained it's not the thing that's in my
in my four my forte but it was a thing
that I kind of enjoyed so I was like you
know the blog sphere was really kind of
popping back up in that space and I was
like let me write a blog and see if I
can do it and talk about gaming and
stuff like that
um that worked out for a couple of years
I did the spawn point blog for a bit
okay um and I was playing a game called
Sound Shapes a bunch which was on the
Vita at that point yes
um and they had this really fun uh
community that was doing content
creation for the game so they were
making user generated content so I would
basically hit people up and was like hey
I saw you put this thing up is there any
because there was like a website you
could do and there was like a message
board in there I was like I'd love to
interview you and talk to you about like
why you're doing this and why you're
making this stuff and it bubbled up and
it got enough traction that the
Playstation blog hit me up and they were
like hey we were gonna do something like
this would you want to run it for us and
it was the first moment where I was like
the connection hit where I was like
first of all a Blog that I read all the
time is hitting me up to be like let's
do content together
and then I was like well enough people
have been reading this that it's gaining
some traction maybe this is a good way
to kind of start fast forward a couple
years people were like okay you're
writing sucks and I'm out
yeah we did the blog we did the blog at
that point uh and I met uh in a game of
2K my my co-founder uh Cicero Holmes of
the show and we popped we were like yo
we had a good thing that they called a
phone call okay
there were no emojis back then I was
smiling in real life no texting for
every five minutes
let's go talk to him so we've had a
hour-long conversation and I was like yo
let's let's do something we had been big
fans of the podcasting space you know we
grew up with the one-up show Giant Bomb
you know all of those things and was
like yeah but there's no space where you
hear a perspective from from black folks
talking about their perspective in the
video game Space is there a way to do
this in a way that feels smart it feels
nuanced feels like it's coming from a
genuine place and also isn't really you
know we're not trying to [ __ ] and Jive
right on this thing because we see a lot
of folks who are like doing that work
and it's and it's working and we don't
want to do that
um and it was great we started the show
we had our first episode uh back in 2013
uh in January it was uh we ripped it off
off the the Jay-Z song We called it now
now let's introduce ourselves
my name is yeah and we started spawning
me back then and you know almost 10
years later it's still it's still moving
which is which is a wild thing to say
out loud because like I've never had a
project that did anything like I've been
a person who started a lot of projects
and then failed on a lot of projects so
I never continued to kind of push that
project forward and I don't know how
it's continued to move besides like
perseverance and finding that you kind
of like a thing consistency is huge and
then finding that you have some purpose
like I think there was a couple episodes
in we have probably gotten into like the
first 30 episodes or so and we got our
first fan letter and it was a cat from
Germany oh wow you had to be a done an
episode around the four pillars of
hip-hop and how they connected to video
games and and we talked about daylight
Soul because De La Soul is one of my
favorites
three three High Rising oh my god let's
go Stakes is higher oh okay okay okay
right and we had that conversation this
guy from Germany was like look I really
wanted to say I I've never thought about
the connection that YouTube had brought
across the table and as a hip-hop fan
I'd never thought about how black
culture has been infused within gaming
since its Inception yeah that did a lot
for me thank you for writing thank you
for making that episode sent that I gave
that as an email because my wife was
like yo you're doing this podcast you're
doing a lot
of money
and I was like here I was like look at
this email and she looked at the email
and she's like okay I get it like you're
having an impact on the world I think
that's the thing that you know when you
you take for granted often just how
these microphones all of the stuff that
we have reaches across the planet
factual and and that message whatever
you decide your message is can have
impact on somebody you've never met
factual
um so it's it's a lot of those things
that have kind of moved the the needle
for for us and and for me uh and have
changed the way that all of this has
worked and kind of it's given me my job
it's given me purpose it's giving me all
the things you've seen me do over the
past 10 years video games and podcasting
were the the impetus for it no that's
tremendous and and the longevity the
consistency you don't kind of carve in
your lane and then I love what you said
about you know doing it for that time
because it's like you know if you're
passionate about it you know I think me
and attic had this discussion and you
know with iops Inception and it's just
like you know sometimes obviously you
get discouraged if you don't get the
reception you you think you deserve but
at the same time it's like after 10
maybe 10 15 episodes
addict we already looking at the like it
was so bad we like your friends don't
wait in the chat yeah and we like fan
you supposed to be my man you know what
I'm saying it's like eight people in
here and I don't see one of them eights
you
you'll see so like I remember having
discussions with with Attica we like yo
you know I ain't really feeling us and
but we sat back and we said let's go
like 10 couple more episodes because
yeah there was a time where like
probably maybe three more months I hope
he was going in yeah we would look at
that we're like damn is is no one really
listen to us and then I sat back too but
I'm like yo but I still enjoy doing this
like I still like it right and then be
like okay let's go get the homies you
know what I'm saying let's go let's go
get you know Saul becomes a guest right
he gets on and we're like okay this
chemistry just like how you know the
Xbox live chats then we four four
trolling you know what I'm saying we
need to call the king can't come through
we sit there we we start to see that
form and then it became even something
else so you know I know what you mean
about about longevity but I wanted to
ask you in reference to I know you
mentioned the fan like that was powerful
right but I wanted to ask you um kind of
like the inflection point also another
one maybe personally where you felt what
you were doing in addition to that
feeling was something special you like
no I think we got something I really
think we got something going on oh yeah
episode 50. I I remember what it was
because we had Evan narcisse on the show
oh you know amazing writer writer of
black panther yes a lot of stuff from
kataku all that kind of stuff we have
Evan RC's on the show and it was
literally the day after he had written a
piece about black hair in video games
he's again he's an amazingly passionate
cat so he's like you know he was like
going through it because of that because
that piece was like a very heartfelt
piece and we got him right after it so
all the emotions were still raw and we
were still trying to figure out what our
Niche was what we were trying to kind of
be out in the world what was the kind of
the vibe and what was the kind of like
reason why we're doing it what was the
north star or what we were trying to do
and that was the episode that sold it
for us that sealed it for us because we
were like we can do a thing and talk
about stuff that nobody else can talk
about just from us being us because we
have a prism that no one else is talking
through that we can if we can fill that
lane in a real comprehensive and smart
way yes because a lot of the
conversations were stupid and they're
still stupid in a lot of the podcasting
space a lot of concentration space
stupid content makes a crap ton of money
oh yeah yeah a lot of views yeah
positivity do not sell I was like and I
was like I'm not gonna do this if I
can't represent what I think smart black
conversation is
and it doesn't do anything for I'm not
excited by it if I'm not doing it it's
easy it's easy I don't want to do it
anymore
disrespectful put somebody face a name
in the title do all that clown to read
like I feel you bro I'm sorry continue
no but I feel you though and again it's
like I I have that conversation in the
back of my mind all the time it's
actually been a blocker to doing stuff
oh yeah because I'm like this doesn't
feel smart this doesn't add anything to
that conversation we talked about a
little bit earlier of like everybody
here is negative everybody's here is is
in their fields in a way that's not
nobody having fun nobody like a game
everybody is ready
yo that's garbage and like bro you don't
enjoy nothing nothing is the most
amazing space because it is the only
place that people get up every morning
complain and come back to you every day
bro if you're not getting paid bro I got
a job
can't get up if I don't like something
why am I gonna get up every day to watch
something I don't like or people I don't
like I don't I don't get that go on my
timeline and complain about Xbox to me
like do you see what I'm wearing on my
neck like right so you complaining the
Xbox I said how did you find me why are
you here we're not even friends like
right go go go talk about PlayStation
stuff over there like but it makes no
sense and they continue to come back
yeah
they think that's so weird if you claim
to love the other side as much as you do
you clearly have don't you're not
enjoying yourself because you're not
doing the thing you claim you love the
most you're coming to the other side to
sit there and look at what other people
are doing that is just weird it's like
going into a crowd of people cheering
having fun and you yelling out yeah
funny thing is that if you think act
when we were growing up right the the
Council worriedness of stuff was never
about it was it was about mine was
better than yours right yeah but the
person that was fighting it still wanted
yours yeah like I I'm not gonna play
that ever no it was it was a jealousy
that you knew came through so it was it
was oh you could say like this
character's but this character this
game's been in this game but at the end
of the day both parties wanted to have
what the other party had and that's the
difference today where it's like are you
really telling me you're a grown man
with the means or grown and you're an
adult with the means to purchase
whatever you want including every single
video game console so you can have the
full array of experiences and you
purposely are saying no I refuse because
this one is this and this I I don't get
it I don't get it there's two rules
break it down break it down there's two
rules of that hurt people hurt people
yeah and people who have nothing else to
do with themselves will always find an
angle to mess with someone somebody else
is enjoyment yes yes
people who you can tell yes don't have
happiness in their lives yes you will go
and try to suck it out of other people's
lives and the third one I'll add I'll
give it to you King is people need to be
validated by their purpose
let's say like I'm the king I always
tell people and you know I can't you got
the best ball for this
you said no one can tell me how my food
tastes yeah yeah so you don't care about
no Metacritic you don't care about no
gamer it's cool right but at the end of
the day some of the greatest games to me
are rated a six and a seven and I don't
care with nobody and that's what me and
King really aligned on that like there's
nothing No One's Gonna tell me because
some Outlet said that it's not gonna
then the the bastards say yo it got
killed out there on such I'm like that's
nice I'm I'm doing it up right now you
know what I'm saying like that's cool
you got I'm having fun like that's the
beginning
you know what's the funniest thing about
me I could be talking Sony craft all day
long yeah Sony Sony this and Sony that I
come up with characters
yeah I see yo this is the new dual sense
2 controller I say I say all types of
stuff right the other war came out well
I was at like thanks I'm at the store
bye I gotta get it I don't put my dick
digital money with them guys I don't
trust them
I get that physical though right because
you know they take their team is about
physical but what I laugh at they in
line they like yeah you know what I'm
saying King gonna have no fun you know
because you know God of War came out
today I'm like work
I'm right with you I come I come from
if you didn't have it your boy had it
you shared it yeah right right we come
from a different thought process and
then when we got cash
um how can I say it like uh well for
myself I can't speak for everybody else
for myself I came from very very uh
humble humble beginnings I come from a
single parent household in the projects
okay
um I didn't know we was on welfare
get this I did not know he's on welfare
until I was 20 years old and let me let
me tell you why I found out that we was
on welfare
we have food stamps back in the day
remember when you get the little booklet
let's go let's go talk about it talk
about it I didn't I just thought that's
that my mom was getting food stamps I
didn't know I did
she didn't make us feel like we was poor
right you understand like I didn't have
that poor mentality she always explained
to me that you know you can do this and
you can do that and you can do
everything but I say this to say
everything we got we earned right so
when I got some money I earned my stuff
I got my stuff and I was proud of him
doing so so I go out and I buy my stuff
and I appreciate my stuff these guys
nowadays feel like they're entitled to
something yes
and this is the problem because you feel
like you're entitled to good graphics
you'll feel like you're entitled to good
sound if you don't like something do not
Patron it do not put your money there
nah I'ma go attack the devs man I know
how the game should have been made I
know you should have did this but don't
attack the person that is having fun
with the thing you don't like bars it's
the wildest thing because it's fronting
for nobody yeah
it's fighting for who it's the wildest
thing to be that mad about somebody
else's Joy one of my favorite Gifts of
all time is this one GIF of this one
small uh little boy and he's he's like
in front of a birthday cake he's about
to blow the cake out and this one little
girl just rushes into into frame and
blows that joint up
that's my favorite one of my favorite
gifts because it's a it's a
representative of the internet and it is
exactly what the internet is like the
internet will try to steal Joy from
everything and it wasn't being a part of
you know the the thrust of of the
content that I do in that respect where
it's like look
in the time that I have you and I have
your ears and your eyes I want you to
come away with that content feeling
something smart or feeling that you know
the conversation was smart hopefully you
gotta laugh and some Joy or if we do get
into some deep stuff like it made you
think about a thing that you weren't
thinking about in that same way or at
least in an adjacent way to at least the
way that we're thinking about it we may
not even agree on half this so we got a
great conversation on the last episode
about AI art our chat was Walling right
there it was like some people was like
yo this is terrible so this is like yo I
understand this people like yo kai
you're you're a jerk for even having the
conversation and I was like look
I'm going to make content around things
that I think are interesting around
things that I find to be on the top of
the mind of the conversation and if you
don't like it you can dip it's small
tools it's not that hard I never
understood this thing where the
unwillingness to have the hard
conversation I just don't know I don't
get it like I don't I just don't get it
like why would you why would you want to
come into a space that never challenges
you ever right because we live in a
space where Arrested Development is real
and we live in a space where people it's
interesting because you know us of being
of a certain age too and you brought it
up King about snapping right like we
were taught to be able to deal with
conflict in a way that was
confrontational face in your face right
and dap it up and and peace out right
some people went further than that yeah
you know about those cats these cats
right all that nonsense right but
the generation that has grown up now
that has had the internet because we
didn't have the internet we were growing
up we were raised through the internet
in fact yeah they don't have a lot of
that ability to be confrontational in a
way that is giving the other person
space to be able to do this
confrontation is this
but that's the thing it's very short
right it doesn't account for a human
um the way that humans actually talk
right and they count for the way that
human emotions are there's a reason why
I'm like if we have beef call me yeah
don't text me preach like if we have
beef call me don't text me but it's all
of those things that they all are an
amalgamation to what we want to get
that's a whole other concept but but I
think that's all like again like the
thrust of the way Swanton me works is
like I want you to come away from this
in a way that feels like we're not just
doing the same thing that everybody else
is doing because that stuff is easy
factual no well said well said brother I
love the that that mindset you know
having like Saab said also just the
ability to have the conversation also
when we do disagree you know even though
we could still end up at the end of it
you on your side but listen hearing the
person out not automatically vilifying
the person and not saying oh you can't
speak to someone because they view this
way or they follow this person and all
of this clicks and you know I call call
it the Bloods and Crips of video games
be throwing up the set hard yo they be
throwing up the set and if you on the
other side you know what I'm saying you
the opposite they really in these
streets banging hard for this and I'm
just like bro it's not that serious
if oh if we have um oh if you have this
one on yeah this person on I'm not gonna
be I'm not gonna watch your show no more
I said well then you was never a fan
exactly see you next week then because
you ain't gonna like this one or
whatever and that's fine you know we got
to be of course it's cool right we got
to be able to have the conversations you
know what I'm saying okay I think that a
lot of the issues that we have is it's
too easy to monetize that kind of stuff
yes and people feel like they can get
something from it and that's people get
too much
satisfaction off of trying to ruin
people's days as well and then you have
people that'll take that same
satisfaction and monetize it in a
YouTube video and Instagram and Tick
Tock and I do think it's like look like
you're never going to truly get rid of
that and I feel like sometimes people
give these people too much power on
Twitter and then you're just enabling
them to do it to another person I'm not
I'm not quoting none of that nonsense
because it's like that you're just
continuing the cycle of nonsense that's
what that person wants that person wants
you to acknowledge them they want that
go ahead I'm sorry because then they're
gonna put that that tweet of someone
saying uh you know the worst thing you
could do to someone attacking you on
Twitter is to even acknowledge them it's
to put any kind of screenshots up
because first off
there's so many ways to get around not
being banned off these social medias and
a lot of the the ones that actually know
what they're doing they will they will
push to a point where they they know
they're not breaking terms of service
and it's just like and the moment you
quote tweet that and you say something
regarded what they said they're like oh
I'm getting to you yeah you know you're
going to see The Tick Tock videos come
up and it just it's just monetization I
think people's always been like this the
difference between now and 20 30 years
ago is social media wasn't there uh when
you have millions and millions and
millions of people that don't have
access to a voice yeah when you give it
to them you'd be surprised at how many
of these people have been around for a
lot longer than we think no doubt now
absolutely well said I know we got it
we're going on time so I want to be
respectful but um yeah man great great
stuff I love the mindset of sport on me
I wanted to talk to you um about the
origin of the sporties yeah I'm saying
let's cook them spawnings and like you
know for those from the round for those
who are not familiar with it explain
what that is and why is the movement of
the sport is important to you so last
year we had our first uh Game of the
Year award show I mean I I'm a big fan
of you know I got your chance to host
the dice Awards a couple years ago that
was huge uh which was a huge deal for me
I've been a big fan of the game awards
and they're coming up on their 10th year
next year yes yes
um but there's always been a space in
between that I felt like was being
missed and it was it was a culture layer
right I think I will say this to the day
I die I think you know
black and brown hip-hop culture is the
thing that moves everything first you
know the first mover is on everything we
are the people to make everything hot
first and then everyone comes in
afterwards and they snatch it up culture
vultures culture vultures and they try
to remix it into something and then
winds up being bad right I know right
um what happened when we stopped doing
Tick Tock dance
yeah I mean I mean I mean what is what
is that conversation of like so how do
you build a thing for the industry as a
new person coming to it or a fairly new
person coming to it that infuses what I
believe to be the some of the best parts
of our culture into that conversation
and doing it while having it be fun and
also hopefully giving space for all the
folks who you know uh are the folks who
are making games uh who look like us
right there's a constant conversation
about like representation in a space
yeah I care a lot about who are the
folks who are making games who who I can
look to and point a young kid at and say
you know the thing that you've been
playing for 10 years or if you know for
the past 10 minutes
somebody who looks like you is making
that too oh you don't always have to be
a consumer you can be a creator of that
and you don't get a lot of people who
are doing the work to Showcase and
Spotlight those things so the idea is
you know we Spotlight devs of color the
the the underlying thing that tell
people is that one day we're gonna get
to a space where we have 100 100
representation from underrepresented
groups minority groups PLC folks where
throughout the whole show you don't see
anyone but a black or brown face someone
from uh from a underrepresented
community in that space respect and
we've gotten close we're still we're
still almost there uh but it's it's uh
the interesting part about is we haven't
gotten it yet because the dev space is
still predominantly white yeah right in
that way uh so we're we're gaining
ground on that thing I think we're
getting closer every year to what that
is last year we had our first show we
had almost 350 000 live views for it
okay uh which was a huge deal for me
because you need good numbers to start
off the gate
we got a dope dope dope music set for
Mega Ray who came through
um and did some Joy Amaze did some dope
joints oh amazing games
super dope stuff and I think you know
the the reason it winds up getting to be
more fun every year is we're adding
small things to her like we're gonna
we're gonna go a little bit bigger on
production this year uh we have some of
the I think some of the most fun names
of awards for for our Awards you know
it's not bubble cries
most emotional game of the year there's
so many ways to die award
or for our best shooter award and that
kind of stuff so they're all references
references to stuff that I've grown up
with and you know memes and things like
that our VR game of the year is called
the Jamiroquai like all that kind of
stuff
so we do a lot of fun things to
differentiate ourselves from what we
think the other game show awards are but
also you know it's it's a growing thing
the game awards wasn't the game awards
in year two yeah right no you're right
we still have a far way to go in terms
of what that is so you know we're going
to be going live uh on Twitch next year
in January uh January 30th at 6 PM PST
we'll be doing that on the front page of
twitch nice uh Xbox is supporting the
show and supporting us this year uh
twitch and supporting us and being a
sponsor this year too we may have some
more sponsor announcements there coming
up soon but I think again it's like
what's the Gap that we get a chance to
fill we get a chance to bring culture
into it we get a chance to bring dope
people that you might never ever seen
before or known of before in the
creative space as presenters and you get
a chance to have
you know this year be alive uh we had
live voting this year for the first time
so every award that is on our show was
voted for by our fans as the nominees
and the winners so that is great so when
stuff goes wild you know like yo why the
hell did that game get it's not my fault
it's not my fault this year it's going
to be me and the fan Rihanna Manuel Pena
hosting it
um so I'm really excited it's just
another layer of how do we build a show
uh that's going to be fun and and kind
of for us bias kind of stuff nah brother
I appreciate it well that was dope yeah
[Music]
all alone
but
[Music]
um no no for real your case I'd be
laughing
um yeah look it that's important and
you're so right you know because I want
to you know get some flowers a couple
Brothers in a space that you know to be
honest you know besides yourself and
everybody you know it wouldn't be
remission absolute like hip-hop game or
some of people for the first time and
I'm like wow you know there's someone
that kind of looks like me and and in
the space and doing their thing kind of
like Pioneers in the space and stuff
like that
um people who actually guessed it on us
um our podcast watch out the BG broke
against HD you know what I'm saying a
couple other faces and stuff like that
and it means a lot it means a lot to see
that and we got to support each other
again we may not always agree on every
single thing our brother's doing yeah
um you know Point standpoint but as far
as like an opinion standpoint but as far
is the movement as far as you know
supporting each other we all do that and
I think that that is really important as
I stand together and I love what you're
doing specifically because we we don't
have enough of that and a lot of times
you know you don't know behind the
scenes you know if people of color
actually involved in the industry and
the technical side I think that's that's
important that's really important so I
love I love the movement love the
sporties what I wanted to ask you is um
in regards to all of that you know and
you're doing all this stuff you're
gaming for good you're doing you know
these great interviews you know what I'm
saying you're doing all that good stuff
you have in my opinion a ton of magic
moments like a ton you know I mean so I
know a couple miles for you but I want
to know your personal when you're like
man like this is big for me like this
this is a checkbox this is like I did
that like that was crazy it's wild too
because it's it's been a really
interesting almost decade and it's I
haven't sat down and Taken full audit of
all the things that have happened I do
think often about the you know cyber
Bond stuff that we did we did the
interview with Sarah Bond oh I love that
interview
um you know getting to meet and hang out
with Phil Spencer and and and them now
being homies that's a wild thing to say
out loud is that the thing dope
um but it's been like the interesting
part about it to be fair is like it's
kind of weirdly not spawnies or spawn on
me related like we've done a lot of
stuff we've done a lot of Firsts in the
gaming industry that I don't think we
get flowers more pictures because it's
your time to talk to them tell around we
were one of the first podcasts to come
out against the conversation around
gamergate at the time that was an
interesting conversation talk about it
we were one of the first gaming Outlets
to ever support
um
uh the right oh no sorry the
conversation around which conversation
[Music]
um
what was it about representative rights
in terms of
um women's right for an abortion okay
the first one to do a charity event for
that uh we were the first ones to do a
show on uh terrestrial radio here in the
Pacific Northwest Let's go people forget
that we were on the radio on the radio
and we've done a lot of stuff like it's
all those layers are in that in that
conversation but to be fair like I've
worked at three different places because
of my job I worked at Intel I worked at
uh Riot games now working at another
studio now uh or firewalk Studios fire
so like literally yeah literally
podcasting from my Brooklyn house table
in the kitchen has gotten me into some
of the biggest doors on the planet bro I
mean we hosted and we had a whole booth
at E3
like it's again it's like all of those
things when you think about like where I
came from I share a lot of the the same
background that you do king you know my
parents were drug addicted I never saw
them until much later in life I didn't
really have a connection to my parents
they were both drug addicts my grandma
raised me pulled me out of the hospital
literally the day I was born raised me
wow gave me video games and I think
about you know I shouldn't have made it
past the age of 25. thank you I'm here
20 20 years later than that for real
thank you that's right doing stuff that
I never thought I'd be able to do
billboard in Times Square do all this
wild stuff it's it's a blessing that I
get a chance to do any of this from the
comfort of my home
with the technology that has been given
to me from many many people smarter than
I am and getting a chance to rock with
brothers who are across the world now
having conversations about this and
about that growth I hope that people
come away from these conversations and
understand that you don't have to go to
college knock all this stuff out you
don't have to I mean I'm a College
Dropout but it's like go to college
[Laughter]
so many Avenues now for you to become
the person that you want to be if you
really do want to push yes yes and I
think that's the thing for all y'all at
home I know you get a lot of that
information from the brothers here but
it's a thing that you need to drill down
to the other parts of the people you
have around you too like I had a really
interesting conversation with a cat who
was like yo I was just chilling with my
boy and I was like yo come with me on
this trip and he was like nah I got
everything here in the hood and I was
like sad for that cat because he went he
went and his life is now changing bro
it's so and just the flipping and please
apologize this is not good you know I
wanna I wanna highlight my brother happy
born day to him because you know I
remember our friendship started at it
and I was just like man like you know I
want you to come out there to E3 with us
like I want you to go you were like [ __ ]
I don't know man he's like I don't know
you know what I'm saying like and I'm
like bro like you just need to see how
things move you know what I'm saying
because I'm guilty of that like just
staying in the Bronx staying in New York
staying in my space in my comfort zone
right and then when you get out and you
start to see the world a little bit more
you start to see events and conventions
and game and then he hit me back he's
like yeah I go break out he's like I
really you know you forced me to get on
that plane you know what I'm saying but
I really enjoying it you know what I'm
saying that even my brother you know he
came up to NY just you know recently you
know said it we took him around and he's
at 40 Deuce with the dudes doing in the
village I care foreign
[Laughter]
you guys the way you guys be active for
years keep in mind years and I'm not
being sarcastic years reasonable you're
gonna eat our pizza you're going to turn
into Superman you're gonna grow up
that's why you guys you gotta be talking
like
me that's all I should need is one thing
back to like every corner spot got that
place all right
let's add it with this
there are so many good pizza spots in
New York that are hole in the wall spots
yes and I will just say this and I don't
want this to sound disrespectful please
there's a difference between pizza and
casserole
Jason
Chicago was in there yeah that's Chicago
that's Casper that's less spot yeah New
York
that's different but I will say this and
I'll give it back to you at it where
addict baby smile is
is late we came back from the city
man I know he came back to the Crayola
I'm still a little hungry you know I'm
like all right so I said I'm gonna put
him more into the chicken spots
you know The Mamas and Papas two people
fries
that man that boy had that thing he was
like oh my God
talk talk to him about that New York
like there's mom and Shop pizzas here
that's not as good as that pizza all
right you should tell the difference in
that pizza right and you could and that
pizza is definitely way better but I
wouldn't say it's like a mile
but here they don't make anything like
that here that chicken that chicken
different KFC had nothing on that yeah
right best thing I ever saw was Obama
fried chicken
spots were kind of losing their their
grip
they make those pizzas like gigantic
yeah like yeah like they're like they're
like fold the pizza addicts like dude
this is too big for me to fall that's
how you know you know it's like the size
of my my my head like you can let it
replace my head put that pizza
between because Jason Ronald just put
God bless
uh uh the Chicago pizza and you know
utensils you know forks and knives
yo you're supposed to just grab your
pizza out the box bow fold it and hold
it yes
get a napkin right there hold that yeah
that's the only attemption we need the
napkins
getting back on for it no no this is a
great it's a great diversion but it was
just like you know the whole thing of
going outside your comfort zone right
you know
that was the first time I was ever even
on a plane yeah like I I've been on like
buses and stuff but I've never been on a
plane and I remember shout out to
Anchorman he was like he was all right
if if he goes make sure he's on my plane
so I make sure you don't get stuck
somewhere yeah because yeah we don't
want your first experience to be a
layover yeah yeah that's true yeah it
was funny is like the whole time Carl's
like yeah man he's like you you know you
go to the press conference you're gonna
go to to the E3 and then we get there
and they change the way that Fan Fest
was done where it was like a raffle it
called one that first one that first
draft when he looking at it he's like
here man he hands it to me I felt guilty
I was like nah man I can't do that like
I generally felt guilty and he's like
yeah just give me your ticket you take
the winning ticket the Willy Wonka
Factory ticket go out there and get it
well and I was like all right so Cog won
that like five times he kept giving his
away to people that just showed up
listening
I just could not my brother came out
there for his first time I promised him
that he was going to get in it didn't go
down they changed the rules and I'm like
nah even if I can't get it he got to go
in and it was dope even if none of us
got picked Microsoft and Xbox did make
it right yeah they made it right they
made sure everyone went that actually
showed up yeah and stayed there's some
people that the mo they started the
rifles like we out they just left they
shot the mostly he's in the chat he was
there but I want to move forward because
I know time is living I want to be
respectful but um I did one of two two
last days I got a quick quick hitters I
got a little extra time okay cool cool
so the first one you gotta explain what
Chicago
is the joining of where the two cities
were that we started the show in so C
was in Chicago I was started it in
Brooklyn I'm from the Bronx originally I
always wrote The Bronx I'm Brett
Brooklyn wow
Chicago doesn't sound good
oh okay okay
yeah but I lived but I lived in Brooklyn
but we actually like okay physically
started this got it okay because I was
like you claim in Brooklyn I'm like he
full body for the South Bronx though
Bronx cargo sounds weird poor cargo
sounds weird and because I'm now in
Portland
uh so it's all those things don't sound
good that's weird that's where bricago
came from thank you for the class shots
about being Royal boy 78 that's New York
in the building I see you boy I see
what's up um all right so that's the
first thing the second thing I gotta ask
because this is what I think it's kind
of the funniest I call it sitcom between
two friends I've ever seen so I need you
to first you know talk about your
friendship with good friends of the
realm Paris Lily who's also been in the
realm here before he's always been in
the chats he already had fun with Paris
in the building but I need to know the
origin of when the cooking will start
because
that man I I can't front car that man
got you so crazy on National
with the Xbox showcase and he had the
controller and that joint said car can't
cook I was like I I was feeling I was
like I don't know if my boy gonna come
back from this one but you came back but
I don't know I still don't feel like I
came back yet I still feel like I'm
still trying you put you on the Summer
Jam
sometimes I'll be talking to Cargo like
watch cow watch him like like be a chef
or something and like this is a giant
inside joke
it's funny because I wanted to one of my
dreams before I got into any of the tech
stuff was I wanted to actually go to
culinary school so it's funny
um but the content that's Paris you
don't even know what you don't even know
what means in Plaza son
the the quick version of it is he was
making a 7Up cake one year and you put
it on the timeline and I was just like
yeah let me give him some some crap it
was like yo your cake looks like trash
and he was like he sent me a video in
response that was like look I don't make
food I make art and I took that and then
chopped It Up made a beat made a video
no made that video put that video on the
internet and then that's when it kind of
started to pop off because people were
like yo this cat made an actual like
video yo you gotta send me that I gotta
find it
so what you're saying is you started
this dude
you
that was the first one that went down
then I forgot what he did after that I
think he did some some other layer there
and then it wound up moving into like
other people's conversations so then it
wound up moving into like uh Traeger
sent him a grill yes I saw that one when
he was with the grill yeah and then they
started making all those videos with him
making food on the grill and calling me
out and then Weber sent me a grill a
little bit ways after that and then we
had this like stalemate and then he did
and then I did a video where I got all
these Cameo videos together so I had uh
Kurt Angle in it it had
uh this is how you do it guy Jordan
in it no I had a big baller brand new
you had them Cameo yeah
it was the most expensive joke
I'm out time out time out I got the
video somewhere it's on YouTube
celebrities doing dry apps on the boy yo
Red Man either this man
red man said stuff that was so mean I
had to pull it out of the video
he was being me I was like yo and I had
to tell Paris I was like yo fam like red
man says some stuff here I'm not I'm
gonna send you what he said I'm not
gonna probably put that because I know
how the internet goes the internet will
wall out and take things in and take it
out of context red man was in that joint
uh brand dude
it was like five or six people oh
something the Entertainer
it's on YouTube it's on YouTube
and I did it to the song these are the
people in your neighborhood oh I'm
walking through and it was like in your
neighborhood and then it stops and then
the next person jumps in and says
whatever so he got was like he was
ethered at that point he was out of here
because it was like on the anniversary
of
of that day hold on one second I got the
link oh please send me that I'll drop it
in I'll drop it in the chat yes please
please I need that in my life so so we
did that and he did his drink which I
didn't know he was doing but he was like
teasing me in the background he was
sending me texts he'd be like yeah we
got this real fun thing we're gonna do
and then he did it and I watched it live
and my life was over that was the people
who walk up on me if they see me and
they kind of understand they see and
especially at gaming conferences like
you guys said it again it said in the
studio link you guys said like a regular
link or something yeah it's not going
through I need the regular later but
yeah cause I'm trying to watch yeah
um but now I get emails from PR
companies who are like yo I'm on team
[ __ ] and cook
like it is like literally people will
come up to me at a convention or a thing
you're like yo he did you dirty yo
did you do a little dirty and that's
messed up but it was it was great
because it was like one of those things
of like I love Paris like Paris is Fame
yeah at this point and the beauty of it
is like you have two brothers who are
like in this space who are showing love
it's all positive people are tired of
the joke now because it's been like two
and a half years now yeah so I
understand that part but every time I
get a chance to like give him some
shades some loving shade and still and
so like I would the only thing I'll say
towards the the the the Paris can't cook
I can't cook
is you should watch the swannies this
year yes oh okay all I'll say is that
you should watch this you should watch
the spawnies this year no no I might I
might be able to take the crown back oh
yo y'all heard that y'all
come through
it'll be Paris and the little dusterian
and bubble
[Applause]
but I wanted to ask the final questions
of that we always have actually a new
segment which is first how did um Lord
how did you find us at LP what's the
first time you kind of came across us we
just do segment we tried it was at E3
way back in the day I forgot who it was
who was at the show but a brother robed
up on me was like yo you need a shirt
so King Green rolled up and was like yo
you need a shirt
bro it was the thing that was dope was
the fact that he didn't say you need a
shirt and was like all right I'm gonna
accept like we're gonna have a like do
you want the shirt you need a shirt
you have like when you're an inside Xbox
and you think that they're part of like
the event where you're getting the shirt
for something in the place he's like
here's you a shirt here's your shirt and
I bet you most these people thought like
okay this is the shirt I don't know what
it's for but I'm sure I'll find out and
then you they get to the whole day was
like wait I never use that shirt
here is a dope thing because I was like
yo this shirt is a really nice shirt
yeah this is a really good design sure
like I'm big on Aesthetics so like the
design was the thing that caught me I
was like
a year after that E3 we were watching
some of the old like uh conferences and
qas we were seeing people with that
shirt wearing and doing qas bro I mean
King like we we were resist it we did
King really pushed us out of our comfort
zone yeah
I just want to give you your flowers
real quick because like you don't get
enough credit like we didn't understand
how important that was right and he's
like no they got to know he's like yo
Carl you doing these interviews you're
doing these interviews attic you're
doing this game playing with them we
gonna give this to the developers that
show the most passion for their game and
they gonna put this on I got people to
this day years later with the shirt King
gave them the old school joints and
developers have moved on and we're like
yo that's crazy so it goes to show the
impact of marketing hustling going out
there being outside in the in the
community and yeah man I gotta give you
a flower like because I didn't even know
you ran down on car that's crazy
um I'm heavily in visuals right yeah and
if you don't if you don't act like you
belong you won't belong all right so I
pulled up and you see me pull up in a
Corvette and I popped the trunk
and I grab out shirts and I hand out I
don't get on the line because I'm going
inside uh ea uh access yep and I don't
get on the line
for myself
I give out shirts to everybody in line
and we got like what 500 000 shirts that
year it was like ridiculous Amounts
is this a good idea you know it was out
of our own money yeah remember there was
no budget back then nobody no money we
sell his shirts out the back of the
truck guy yeah it was like 900 a person
I remember that and and you know we have
a custom guy here those are high quality
shirts you can wash them and the stuff
still be there they last for years and
these guys was like no we can't be
giving them away I shipped them to
California to to our family member Aunt
out there shot the bone slave in the
chat too I see our Cali team but I knew
these guys had to go and work yeah so
I'm from street team yeah I'm from boots
on the ground I used to hand out flyers
so you know when you can't give with
okay this is how Flyers go for nobody
that understands what gold
you go inside the Chinese restaurant or
whoever whoever you work for giving you
your fire is to hand out the people
facts if you stand there with them like
this nobody's gonna take a fly out your
hand right you have to be aggressive so
as a young kid at 10 years old I'm
aggressive here you go you need to fly
you need a flyer here you go here you go
put it in people's hands so when I'm
going to give you a t-shirt first of all
this is a 30 shirt so you better take it
but at the same time I'm marketing us I
Believe in Us so much that once you see
the quality of the shirt you're gonna
say who the hell is this dude let me
look up this show and then you look up
the show then you're like oh they dope
so here's the thing that's smooth about
King too King did the exclusive joint I
don't even think you remember this part
but I think you because I know you have
a marketing mind for it I know you do he
had the exclusive white with the gold
joint he was giving out the black with
the gold joints and I was like yo what I
want that white
we had the official joint yeah I was
like
we had like seven different colors the
white one was one of them I think like
up until recently the only one that had
a green one was Tim Dog yeah it got to
the point where developers felt the way
every year we came and they didn't get a
shirt yeah they were like yo where's my
joy that we like yeah you didn't have
enthusiasm about your game yeah if you
didn't you know uh
show that passion because we're there we
want to showcase you we want to show you
in your best life so when we go to a
developer and we like you'll talk about
your game he's animated he's just yo
here you go get this shirt so we go to
the next uh developer and you're quiet
you ain't getting the shot you want to
see the passion you want to see the
passion now that's real salute I had to
ask that and the final question that we
asked earlier every percussion in the
realm I need more cards top five video
games or franchises of all time
Metal Gear three oh no in no particular
order either baby Metal Gear three four
a.m those should die oh
uh running gun okay and
[Music]
uh
oh man why can't I think of it one more
zybots is a really good oh you take it
back don't wave at it
running gun
running gun was so dope because it was
like the two cabinet we were watching
each other play basketball like that man
I mean the the the the the fifth the
sixth one that would have to go in there
of course is any Mortal Kombat game
because
I want to get some deep Cuts in there
guys do those deep those people had to
do your Googles
and favorite console of all time and why
oh favorite console of all time has to
be the Sega Genesis
I think Eternal Champions was the thing
man that just changed my life like
Eternal champions
that was that was probably one of the
first times I had actually seen a black
character in a in a fighting game
plus it was just like you know Sonic
even though I'm not a Sonic fan now
Sonic then was like yeah did you get an
internal um Champion CD yeah yeah
yes and the smell of a new genesis oh
yeah oh my God that was so good the
smell of a burnt cartridge I just like I
just love stacking the boxes the black
with the with the gray stripes and you
lean them and you see the labels on the
side or yeah you look at you feel like
you know what I'm saying you got your
little collection like I hate it when
D.A wanted to do their own with the
yellow tags
one box of the yellow tabs
but look I appreciate you for your time
and absolute pleasure bro I could talk
to you way longer but I was trying to
figure out like we gotta be careful but
brother an absolute pleasure we love
what you do in this place this is long
overdue where can I find people find you
what you got going on next to tell the
realm first of all thank you all for
having me we gotta we gotta do the the
the remix version too you got to bring
it all on me come rock with me
um look you can check out the show we're
on podcast platforms all around the
world you can check out new shows every
Monday 6 a.m EST 9 A.M PST is where you
can find a new episode we're doing a
really fantastic one with tremel Ray
Isaac who used to work at ilphonic he's
now over at uh lithos as their head of
Art and we had a great conversation
around AI art and all the controversy
around that so please check that out uh
on on Monday uh and yeah twitch.tv
spontaneous where we do the show live
every Wednesday 6 p.m PST uh sponties is
coming to you live in direct we're gonna
have a real fun show uh January 30th 6
p.m PST it's a lot of psts and a lot of
sixes
[Laughter]
um but please check out the show I think
this year we're we're trying to get to
this other level where this is going to
be the year where we get to really push
and we get a chance to say look if you
think we did something dope before under
no like we had no budget trying to
figure it out pulling it out from from
the bootstraps yeah a little bit more
budget this year and we're trying to
make that next step so you know having
good viewership will be really really
big in terms of that so please please
please do that and watch the show and
again thank you so much for having me
and it will be in Year 10. from January
let's go shooting for shooting for
episode 500 very very soon damn that's
insane but look you guys apparently is
in a space you're doing it you do
Inspire so many people you know what I
mean I think like the Danny Peng is and
you like you guys have been doing it and
it shows like okay there's a lane
there's a model you know what I'm saying
of Excellence that could be followed
professionalism you don't have to tear
nobody down to bring yourself up and
love what you're doing I'm putting the
links in the chat go support you know
what I'm saying go support about to go
hit that up the spawn on me joined
absolute pleasure Lord attic once you
get your balls off to um my main Lord
Khan before you leave you'll see just
send them off right
I appreciate you coming on giving us
your uh perspective and your history on
it uh they they always be joking with me
because uh I I wasn't diapers for the
majority of your guys's early early
years uh you know I can't relate to most
of anything I've been to the arcade two
times in my life and only one of them I
played anything on it uh and uh last
week uh they were They're laughing at me
because I said it seems like a nightmare
to have to go to the arcade for an
upgrade
toodles to you guys and you know I I
think people in the the comment section
like get that confused like it's a joke
yeah people be acting like I generally
like disrespect like you better get that
young boy listen it's like people people
like that banter so I just keep up with
them like relax it's not a big deal
it's all love it's all jokes lord it's
soft a little setting off the Lord card
before he joins us now man thank you for
coming through brother again I I'm
always partial to people from the Bronx
you know I'm sorry I'm sorry but uh you
know what it is it's the stories that
come out of that because we all came
from that space where it's like you know
your your gaming history is determined
by you know what your parents were able
to give you in and and all of that
appreciation that we have today for all
those things the way we talk about games
with such reverence and why it's
important that we remember those things
uh comes through in everything that you
do man and I hope like like Cox said it
inspirational all of us when it comes to
what we strive for in the gaming space
so keep it up man it's a pleasure to
have you on the show thank you thank you
a little pleasure Lord King any final
words for the Lord God spawn on me I'ma
tell you man
um very rare that I get the chance to
hang out with an individual that is from
the same uh side of the earth probably
probably around the same blocks too
probably
metrax
said vetrex and it warms my soul right
because
um a lot people don't understand it and
and only somebody that had it that
experienced it can understand it I love
everything that you're doing I'm
definitely tuning in to the spawnies
this year to see exactly
I'm waiting for them
I'm surprised no Paris in the chat today
definitely gonna check out that uh show
because
um I was on dcx Friday at uh 9 00 p.m
and we were talking about AI art and
it's it's a huge controversy so I want
to hear your guys takes on it um I'm
gonna you know
the conversation is deep it's deeper
than what people think because it leads
to something else you know but um I just
want to see if y'all touch on that stuff
too so I do appreciate you showing and
hanging out with us man all the way
through so thank you so thank you for
rocking with us enjoy if I don't hear
from you again Happy Holidays yeah it's
gonna be lit hopefully we get to link
all the conventions and stuff will link
up immediate won't work we already know
we got stuff cooking it but I'm so glad
we came together finally longer with
them it was funny we was in we was in
Washington I'm like why I gotta be in
Seattle for us
it took us this long to finally actually
licked but we've been trying it it was
so dope bad it actually you know hang
out and just link and Vibe with you bro
good brother love to see what you doing
man salute the Legendary Collection Adam
sport or me enjoy your day brother for
sure much love y'all thank you so much
for having me again again y'all are one
of the best shows on the planet and
continue to put out fantastic really
smart and funny work you all inspire me
all the time with how y'all push and you
need people to push you and I see how
hard your work I see who you pull in and
I see how good and awesome the community
is and again like that is a testament to
all the wonderful work that you all have
been doing over these years so thank you
mad love to everybody in in the Kingdom
whoa It's always dope to to be able to
be here with y'all uh yeah we'll
definitely get some dope things in in
the new year for sure
thank you brother my man salute you
already know so I'm gonna get the super
chess and then with a lot of transition
because the Lord said you got a lot of
show left
all right and we got pixel bit G
remember for two years remember for 36
months exactly uh happy holidays Lords
as an Atari clico and Aquarius kid shout
out to the moms thinking that the game
was gonna burn the TV out yeah yeah all
that excuse all the time
him on the Summer Jam stage when you did
the Showcase and you had that controller
that said
he had to take over the show I had to
take over show with the celebrities yo
he had a whole celebrity crucial
look I gotta watch that I gotta watch it
all I saw was Ethan I never knew there
was a takeover
stews all the audience watching that uh
yeah he got him the E3 to form that
Spirit Bomb and threw a right atom with
that the messed up part about it is I
didn't understand it
I felt
I was like what's this damn he caught a
bullet now I understand now I understand
it he waited you waited and he got he
got his time until he got his time no
doubt I see you brother that was
hilarious no no so how many we got a lot
of superchargers
cause we ain't got that much show left
this is the last show of the Year
exactly
let's get five dollars Super Chat
playing custom Halo games with the Lords
yesterday was the highlight of my month
thank you for letting me join in and
happy birthday attic blessing that was
so much fun let me tell y'all what what
I don't like is on community day when we
say it I get a text message uh can I
join in or is it just y'all it's a
community it's Community Day come out
have fun enjoy we play games that's what
we do
bro that was fun and yeah shout out to
everybody who creates and forwards that
is Bonkers what they were doing they
just they gotta find a unique way of
like using that content to their benefit
because it's just like if you go on
there like almost every Halo map you
could think has been remade or at least
the most popular ones they got they got
so much different variety of content on
there you don't even have to do like
competitive stuff you don't want to we
we literally played a remake of the
boulder gang of mini game from Mario
Party that's about one person to be at
the Top shooting these Boulders down and
the rights have to climb them out and
it's only been out since when when is
this updated for like a month for like a
month so question do you have to build
everything in Forge or could you import
things also so I could take someone's
word for word world and make something
else on it myself nice oh wow that's
kind of crazy right that it's only been
about a month but Halo is supposed to be
dead why is that
actually apparently the
the audience that was playing it as like
drastically went up and it's not like
the oh the other like Seasons where like
it would go up for a couple days and
then go down it's been like a consistent
rise you know I knew that that it's
really doing what it's supposed to I've
been seeing like people like Chris Ray
Gun playing at like almost daily oh
that's crazy so what you're saying is
multiplayer games with a single player
component
has legs
Super Chat sir yeah
shout out to Chris dude because he's he
he's just recently become addicted to
vampire survivors oh
another one in the face yeah ray gun oh
he's on it oh he's on it okay okay I
gotta holla
then we got Force the legend member for
two years five dollar Super Chat let's
get let's give EA tons of credit for
embracing the Black Culture video games
Need for Speed underground NBA Street
Volume 2 NFL streets they deserve love
yeah I'm really hearing great things
about this new Need for Speed I might
have to might have to cop
then we have to after we get the um the
Game Pass family this year yeah yeah I'm
waiting I I could be patient I know
that's coming yeah
well there we have Need for Speed
it's not under it's not underground it's
something else I forget what it's called
um Obamacare 9-1-1
I'm done huge fan thanks uh thanks for
making Amazon delivery driving
entertaining to you guys by chance have
a Discord server No Lick should be in
the description
and if we can't find your scriptures I
definitely want to uh Channel page
podcast YouTube channel page all our
information in the about section it
should be there but don't at me while
you're there
you're gonna have your personal Discord
yeah
we have black Ronin three five seven
five dollar Super Chat hoping we have
the khalifes in a few years to combat
Achilles as a mainstream awards show
happy holidays to the round that'd be
crazy yeah we got a support shout out to
fatal the Baptist on Twitch right now he
said Redman and Montel Jordan went in on
pattern
he remember he remembered to take over
the break's over the garden
let's go man but then he came out with
super ugly yeah that was that
shout out to Lord Carr Parkchester in
the building for Chester what up six
train what up yeah shout out to the
emptiest Macy's ever yeah
that's where you go get your stuff yeah
cause ain't nobody ever in there
salute for Chester happy holidays to the
Lord that everyone in the realm shout
out to uh
JD gamer five dollars from chat member
for two years shout out to the Lords but
I got a rep I've had them all and
Detroit style pizza is incredible never
tried I heard Detroit I heard Detroit
what do Detroit do why why who is
Detroit that's only Chicago in New York
we got people we got people Detroit in
there I heard I heard of forte be
popping off what do Detroit News listen
don't see me
don't let chick chick hear you man
foreign
and we have flame remember for 26 months
shout out to Flame lagnet's finest yes I
can't believe it's the last IOP of the
Year thank you for the amazing content
y'all and thanks for putting up with me
oh yeah have a great holiday thank you
for everything you do smoking all love
it
we got something else
oh yeah hi the homie 100 Super Chat
thank you so much happy holidays to the
Lords thank here's to a great 2023 see
you next year absolutely brother little
brother thank you brother thank you
crazy like the support you give the
community
amazing shout out to you for being on my
team you was my security detail and Halo
infinite that that chivalry I had you
was in the corner anybody came through
me and attic put the trucks to the front
and you was in the back if anybody slip
past and you were spotting you know
that's my man in Halo he was he was like
behind the door crouched I was on the
staircase in case they tried to go
anybody came to us getting that work in
Halo infinite on that birthday stream
yeah go check yo check out that birthday
tree
so fun like we all yo we we wild for
these things
just just go listen to the
disappointment in slow motion yes
these dudes he's like he's like how you
gonna let them do that yes like me and
valakin literally pulled up he jumped
out grabbed the flag we did a UE and
left yeah
absolutely absolutely one more one I
didn't have the gravity half of that
that's why that's why
maybe you didn't think that I decided to
do it right at that moment I like I
liked how I decapitated the birthday boy
in the Jeep as he was coming across
yeah
yeah he played Halo for almost four
hours yeah
he right he right because then we have
metallic clouds five dollars for chat
New York Pizza the best pizza in the
world enjoying the show yeah he would
know that's right
exactly Boombox stand up oh
Matt Jimenez he's gifted five IOP
memberships thank you brother appreciate
that matters oh
boy
here we go and I think we have a gender
reveal let me play with your joystick
five dollars we just soft I know I've
been M.I.A but I just want to say all I
want for Christmas is you and if you
want some pics of my jersey for
Christmas
personally
[Music]
it's just gonna be one of those things
where we're at we're at like E3 it keeps
yo look at this man
yo let me play with their ferocious
return in the middle in the middle of
interviews
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right do you got control yeah he got
control he got control
hold on let me get my list up yeah I
could try my best who said I brought my
list all right so we here we're here for
that section right now I can't forget
you know what I'm saying
see Bobby you said what's wrong with
playing with all this joysters oh come
on CW come on man
what I say is they own no doubt but you
you'll be hilarious you know what you
doing right now you know what you doing
hey CW you like to play with joy six God
bless
it's all good it's so good have fun all
right
up a little bit
um addict scroll it up a little just to
screen up a little bit slightly up up
the other way you got the cheeks emojis
inside
all right cool we got that we gonna do
this games of 2020 to the Lords are
going to rank we're gonna pick oh he got
it wrong let us in your Google you got
we see in your Google now we're seeing
all right Google all right yeah
all right all right so we ready to go so
so act man you want to explain the rules
so how this gold is we got the tears we
got all the games pretty much right the
2022 if the Lord's gonna rank them
what's without the rules is to this the
so the rules are it's a little bit
different than when me and King when um
the rules are that we have to agree
where all of these games go but there is
a caveat like everyone all of us have a
three veto rules so at any time if any
of us feel like
the other one shouldn't put that game
there they could hit that veto and put
it where they want to we got three but
yes but you and the only way to overrule
veto is with another veto
so you you can veto someone's veto but
is it really worth that you could
potentially use two vetoes for one game
okay keep my vetoes one day now here's
the thing so the game comes up now let's
just say so basically it's the consensus
right is who
all of us got to vote together like the
who got the majority vote where it stays
in the category that's how yes
did y'all come up with all these other
games yeah oh goodness
so where are we starting what chat where
do you want us to start which game which
game do you want us to start
I just pick one I just I just know the
first one oh the first one you want to
give them the first okay okay okay no
doubt continue continue which game will
soak up the most vetoes I'm gonna take
the first one I see so you better hurry
up all right Steve Jersey check around
it
I'll give it a b
I'm going
what's going on
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go B I'm gonna go
B I'm gonna go B I really like mine I'm
like [ __ ] hey not like I like I like
grounded a lot I think I can agree with
B it's just beef solve haven't played
grounded all right so we overruled you
you want it you want you want you want
to use that overall
like I can get good listen I could put
ground in it hey but I I want to save my
Visa I would I would have probably
vetoed if you try to act yeah yeah but
if we gonna go beef okay okay so let's
go next one it feels like a very b game
that's fine
all right
um solve pick one yeah let's do it like
that yeah let's do it I like that
all right the only time that we will do
another one for the chat now sorry guys
you got a Super Chat tell us what game
if only other time we're gonna do
another one all right let's go let's go
one with one that's my heart
yeah yeah
[Applause]
Wow Let's go with the ascent
I'm saying that the strong D
no I'm gonna go I'm gonna go see
I would say d as well oh I ain't
fighting for it
I love a set y'all fronting on a
sentence
has not reached this potential
game I thought the game was dope I
thought the isometric stuff was
fantastic I just thought that it was
Half Baked I I would have gave that game
an ass if I could oh man
was it in some glitches at the beginning
that's why yeah okay sorry I'm not gonna
fight out I love herself if it was for
Cog
I Gotta Throw Paws out there then
there's no strong Deeds
I said that I said that and Carl told me
to put it in there anyway they said the
scent was last year oh so they didn't
know it got to go off it's got to go off
here we talking 2022 no he's right he's
got to go off there goes that no he's
looking at bushes
that does not count that does not count
no he's
you know why I came up on the list y'all
by fault it was we looked at all the
games in 2022 and it came on I think it
came out on other other platforms at
that point oh PlayStation yeah whatever
they got a madly yeah so that's how it
is
correct correct okay
he going with the big guns early we're
not even saving okay are we going with
this or are we yeah yeah
they super chatting that's s tier s
I'm good
I'm a veto if you veto anything but an
ass listen I'm saving my choice
did we hear the Lord say strongly
no you didn't hear that
thank you
all right soft pick now scorn
[Music]
see
it's going to see what's going on
there for me a d you know what I agree
also we split oh we split
so so King explain to me why this is a c
yeah tell me you think I'm supposed to
be using my veto no no no no
eyes since we're split down the middle
one two of us got to convince the uh one
of the person and the other one
um I can tell you guys to see uh the
story was uh wasn't there was
non-existent
um
and uh
then why you pick the C dude listen let
me I'm gonna tell you because it's not a
d but I'm gonna tell you why and um and
they made it seem like it was something
else other than a Puzzler yes right so
uh for the bamboozlement you would have
got a B but for the Bamboozled man you
can see now aesthetic wise an atmosphere
wise I'm a huge fan of Geiger
so it it it captures everything about
his creepiness and inside his brain and
um of alien and Prometheus law so when I
was playing it it felt like an extension
of Prometheus so I really can't
disrespect it and throw it as a d
because I thought it has potential but
it has to have a c because all I had to
do was fix two things a little bit more
action and a little bit more story cloud
city
so we can hear you I just don't so I
just don't think even with the immersion
and the art style is enough to justify
it bumping up a letter like because
because like in terms of gameplay story
I mean it was a puzzle but I felt like
it wasn't it wasn't shown as one it was
never Market it was never shown as a
puzzle I feel like that action yeah
I don't feel that strongly about it I
could go right I I could I could you be
convinced that it could be no
I don't feel that strongly about it see
Balaji the reasons that that King said
like it it was more of a Puzzler than it
led on to be it felt like it was
supposed to be kind of this this first
person sort of atmospheric walking
simulator type thing
um and then it's like they've told the
line between some combat and no combat
which is just weird they should have
just stick to the no combat to me they
should have really leaned into the story
and the atmosphere to make it you guys
keep talking like it's a d but why are
you giving it a c you like yeah D is
egregious D is the worst thing on the
list yeah
D is not a fancy Grace
I'm dead yeah nah bro no I mean yeah you
might you might get destroyed at home
but it's still plastic again I don't
feel strongly enough about it to try to
overrule anything I'll drop down to a d
it's fine
there we go nobody had to use the veto
um we got Tom 9092
all right let's go um let's have some
fun
let's have some let's go Ninja Turtles
Shredder's revenge
Ninja Turtles I'm gonna go I'm gonna say
hey I'm gonna go I'm gonna go B but I
could be convinced to a I I I'm I'm
leaning either way but I think B's Fair
yeah what is soft light with the Ninja
Turtles Revival turtles in time it's it
is it's a b and it's a b because it does
everything that we loved about those old
games and it brings it forward
ultimately
it doesn't if I'm going to compare it to
something right right and we don't
really see this if you look at a game
like River City girls which would be
really like that's a game that's it it
takes the genre a little bit forward and
even moving it even more forward into 3D
space if you compare it to something
like a seafood it's
it doesn't attack
real quick
um I did put vampire survivors in here I
have no clue why it's not on this list
you can ask Hogs
so we'll just do vampire last okay
so yeah it's a B for me just because it
gives us more of what we know and we
love and it polished it up yeah but it
isn't it it doesn't really bring the
core forward so King are you are you
going to you
and you gotta go hard for did you paint
your characters
yeah I think all the vetoes are gonna
happen at the end yeah
oh awesome nights is the next one I'm
gonna force people hands okay Dawson
Knights is the next one next and nobody
oh yeah it's next and no week D's
all right so I don't have an opinion but
let's start like okay we're going to
start with the people who put in the
most work with it so obviously solving
addict right yeah I put it in the most I
haven't even seen the the loading
screens let's get it solved solve what
is your consensus so where is it going
where's where is it it's going bro
and if
I I think it's a c because
see you I think B is good the the story
stuff really does hit after a bit like
they get kind of they kind of do get
that part right
right but everything else like I just
don't feel like you had the template to
make to build off of it make something
great and you went left kind of for no
reason
um and I just don't I don't think it
worked to its favor to do you know to
have it be like a freaking loot game and
I just don't like that so yeah it's a
scene it's a c okay I agree with that
I'm not gonna be I'm not gonna talk on
that I I think the quality it makes it a
c but the rest of the game makes it
nothing else yeah all right okay yeah
Lord Metroid two dollar Super Chat real
quick
TMNT as an aid has couch Co-op it brings
back all the stuff that we love about
that genre and then when when I finished
it I was like I'm done and that that's
kind of the way I felt and I was hoping
I didn't feel that way but that was the
case
all right King King
God of War
we go first me personally yeah playing
it and how boring it is oh no same thing
that has been doing okay
I'm gonna go with a strong B
B
okay so it does all it okay it does the
same thing that shredded Revenge did why
come on now let's go
the hell out of this
this is crazy if we use this one
let's go
you finished it
where is ragbock
I want to say s but it's an a like I I
think that wait why do you want to say
yes
because it was a fantastic experience
but at the same time I don't think
it's Eldon ring quality and for me to
put it with elder ring means it would be
Elder in quality yeah the world didn't
think it was Elder ring quality either
clearly it can't be an essay
so we got two we got two A's yeah no
question are we gonna are we gonna we're
just putting them in the position
correct we're not settling which one's
better than which one yeah we're not
doing it we're not settling which way we
just put them in a position okay so if
you have to you're aligning where you
where are you are you we already know
King's vetoing regardless we got to see
first we gotta see if it's a majority or
is it what is the majority
I I'm not even close to finishing what
I've played is an a cool not cool isn't
it cool so it's an a by majority
it gets you behind to be
today oh Vito
oh so yeah
do you want to use another veto okay
yeah I use my feet on that again
[Applause]
and we get to hear Kim fruits and a plus
one Amino childhood
um
so I don't have much input here um I
want to see I think C's fair I don't
think you deserve nearly as many of the
games
I I think the whole Zeitgeist around the
cats and the pets watching it it kind of
elevated it like people were really it
like it was like oh my God we have a cat
game and it was just like everybody and
it was you know it was it was good
quality it was but when you go when you
play it it's kind of very linear
um it isn't like you don't you're not
making really jumps by yourself
everything is kind of predetermined okay
in order for the cat to be cat-like
where you know cats don't really make
mistakes like that right they may fall
every night again but not really okay so
that kind of takes away from the uh it
don't have a jump button either oh it
jump it jumps it jumps but it jumps
directly to a spot oh my God of War
[Music]
Last of Us remake part one
oh where are we putting it so
I'm taking a chance to touch
it I'm going to go
the game is still amazing we know this
but I think three points for because of
the fact it's real yeah
I'm gonna say B it's not even say a s
tier game we know this right but the
issue just comes down to damn oh and
it's original form and it's an original
form it's asked here wow well it will
an amazing game or but it's a b because
they stripped uh half the game can the
argument be made it even a remake remake
remake of a rebate it's still better
than 90 of this list so we should give
it an a no I wouldn't even say it's
better than 90 of this list I'm not
gonna say you got games better than last
of us I just you know what it is I think
I think the gameplay overall the first
it got so much improved in part two
um
yeah I think B fits this this is
literally the actually third time today
remaking it oh the second time they're
remaking it I actually feel like this
gameplay is starting to wear its tear on
people because I saw it with God award
people were saying I'm kind of getting
tired of the Sony template yeah that's
why it's a beat down a chat the chat is
kind of in the garage
Michael Askew remember for 26 months
can't beat can't be an a for the third
release
uh it's my turn yes I don't think anyone
else picked one did it
okay so um
I'ma pick
midnight sense
you know where I'm at
I think I think it's a b oh yeah I'll go
B yeah I think it's a b okay so I think
I haven't played it
I think I think I think the lack of
vision is the only thing keeping it from
being an a I agree I agree okay cool
perfect let's go I thought I've got to
fight your heart all right so yeah Lord
Metro to us who's had the last of us is
an old game and a boring one at that
right yeah
let's
as thus Falls
I'm afraid I downloaded it didn't play
it I think it's a b
soft I mean you voted first
hmm the devs are listening
[Laughter]
I think
oh oh he about to betray me again
we have it over God for breakfast
King misused his powers
we'll refine that later over about that
that's gonna be the best beat you got
it of course you can jump tears no we
can't no yes we can obviously you did
not watch r r with the Lord hold up once
we we can't once we move once you move
that's it
I'm gonna make level it's a bit and I
love this game but this is the strongest
B I could give okay yeah because I
invited fantastic story I do think that
but gameplay wise
it's it's that gameplay and the
multiplayer keeps it up as a b because
it's getting [ __ ] B getting crazy
right there all right who's up
um it would be king king
another another blow to you Sony dudes
oh no Gran Turismo
he only got one veto left I don't care
I'ma say c
I'm gonna say yeah you're challenging me
I'm gonna say B why I feel like the
quality is is enough to make it a beat
right here you played it yeah I played
it okay okay
did you buy anything
you don't have to though that's an
option
it's a b
take him you said B
yeah realism yes
them cars though and
some of them it's yeah it's like it's a
game you really want to play inside the
cockpit post yeah yeah you don't really
want to play it outside
why not though the library the three
libraries
yeah yeah all right
I was I was trying to get that last veto
out of Kings
so so we got how many bees two two it's
to see VC versus
both of you I feel like both of you
don't care about this guy game enough to
use a veto yeah I don't know why you use
it oh yeah yeah that is correct that is
very correct let's put it in the seat
wow
I'm saying C
to be es have it yeah
it's as good as God as a war
[Laughter]
side you
it's gonna go at the the very first one
in there I don't care I don't care if
it's the first beat it's just the best B
you got
look at look at adding starting trouble
we have no age yet that's crazy yeah get
him out of there
get him right where he belong crazy yo
fate of the basic kick is violated yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh I think it was King
no king pig no he picked Gran Turismo
boy you know okay
um yeah let's go there let's do it
Horizon forbidden West see
oh nah that's a B I didn't even play it
though that should be I played that's
very small that's that's a b Twitter hey
that's that's you could make I think
that's an a I think that's it
no I'm serious the only reason I feel
like God of War was uh it wasn't an S
but it was an a I do feel like Horizon's
not as good as God of War but it's still
an S quality thing King let's not get it
twisted God of War isn't B Because of
You not because of me yeah
so wait wait so can we make it can we
make the argument that Horizon is a yes
I could yeah even though again it has it
has the same issues as the first one
half of me with the the the the open
world that kind of doesn't do a lot
different but but you know everything
about it is top tier it really is I
think I just think to me it's the world
and Halo it's the world and alloy that
kind of after a while just grates on me
but it it is a name
right it look like it's the first hey
what but what if the guy uses his veto
is is the guy using his veto see I don't
care about anything else
okay I did what I came to do okay
it can stay yeah like I said you are
using this beach
all right let's go all right let's go
uh that it would be me okay what's up
Destiny witch Queen oh let's go I defer
to y'all I'm going hard in the paint on
this I'm going hey oh okay I'll go a
because a lot of people that Destiny hey
this is one of the best campaigns
outside of it that's not this is a good
campaign for destiny this is one the
story of cyberthorne and the witch Queen
is literally one of the best stories in
gaming and paid off in classic Bungie
Halo 3 level Campaign design so I was
ready to feed I was ready I thought I
was glad I was ready so okay that's what
that's what I mean I think a is fair
which Queen is crazy regardless how I
feel about the current state of Destiny
which Queen was still a fun time yeah
whiskey was amazing all right all right
so um I'm up call gear up all right I'm
gonna do this Seafood hey Seafood
I'm fighting who want to smoke who won
it
you guys stand up let's go that's it so
repo Birdie's cool B fix your mouth
let's go with
Court of the Lamb
he's supposed to start filling up yeah I
think it's an a
yeah I think okay
it's had some performance issues and
some instances like it
but apart from that everything that game
does with this envelope of cute this is
so ridiculous I actually think this is
one of the few games on this list that
could be close to being an ass it's an a
it's definitely I got a called the lamb
I'm with you
can't say it it's better than God it was
let's go to the best game on this list
shout out to I want to play some
baseball
eight here baby
okay
first it is a tier it continues to be
the best and only simulation that we're
getting is it doing more of the same
though that maybe that that's why it's
not a and not s that's right it could
even it could even be audio that it's a
b because it's just more the same but
when you play that's the thing this is
to the point now where you have to play
it for a while to start seeing the
nuances of what they add and it's a lot
you don't see it immediately though but
it's a name all right I'm with you let's
go I'm gonna be this show baseball
all right so it's it's my turn
um
you know what I'm pinnamon oh this is
spicy intimate
all right so I finished it
I want it for the y'all I have not
played it yet
um
phenomenal story phenomenal story
um the art style is going to be
off-putting
but I gotta go be I gotta go B I had to
admit it's a controversial one there's
no doubt but that murder mystery is
phenomenal I I really if again you have
to like the time period if you don't
like it you don't like the our star is
not gonna work for you but I think
pentament is a b okay let's see I'm
gonna go see I I played like an hour of
it and I just couldn't do it no more all
right so one so we gotta need uh one of
you two to break the the tie or not okay
I'm going with a beat all right well I
would say I would say on default it's
probably a b when I play it it made me
oh
oh
you only got one veto left so B you got
so you got it as a c
mm-hmm
I'm vetoing your veto oh okay
no no
I gotta live to find them your
convictions
not but he did
vetoed once but he didn't want to Buck
Up you did it you did it no you did it
out of hate you died
I did it because I truly believe that
game below
I truly believe God Saturday
Somerville is I I I know it's on here
it's this one no that's that's no that's
not that's that's the internal spot uh
what's this one that says uh L Elman
what the hell is
yeah I guess they didn't put on here
some of them it didn't work God you
could ask a cog I did it all okay see if
you can get that but anyway all right
it's no big no we ain't gotta fight for
that crazy let's go let's go we're gonna
do all that all right so um Madden's up
Madden's up
yeah man
um I thought it was cool oh oh no that's
me okay I'm going I play D
oh D and I'm fighting
that is the most exploitative of this
man's death football game this is the
most janky buggy even NFL players like
Madden this is the worst like they
disrespect that is that is my D that
that's probably no it should be an F
that is my worst dream right data it's
very disrespectful what they did with
Madden
okay
yeah I was mad I was mad let's go
the last a recruit no no are we all
saying it's oh yeah we're finished yeah
I'm sorry man is nope and I love Madden
they got me bro I was mad I thought they
was gonna try to do something yeah it's
personal for me I'm sorry
no I think it's it's in the UK because
of uh yeah all right um oh let's have
some fun let's go
let's do nobody Saves the World
nobody Saves the World Graham Lloyd in
them
um thought it was a fantastic little
game I'm gonna go be I'm gonna be I
thought they had a lot of depth to it
um the different shapes and stuff like
that different forms and stuff like that
didn't play it okay I didn't play it to
be the moment you could change it to a
rat out there
that's perfect it belongs right next to
the rest of the Sony's stuff
yeah
yeah like I said the last array crew
and it's a it's a c for me uh played it
a bunch at a paxis
um I like the the the co-op aspect of it
um
but I beyond that I really I haven't
played more of it so yeah based on what
I played of it it was fun it was still a
little bit janky writing but um but to
see to me
um see okay see if you guys see I played
it shout out to the team
um my my issue is the graphical for that
I like the concept I like two-player
Souls I like Souls that I could get help
so that it spoke to me but I didn't feel
graphically it hit the way it's supposed
to so it could be you know what I mean
so yeah I I I'm not gonna fight y'all if
you're happy to see I'm not gonna wow
time just jumped I thought we had 20
minutes ago ah shout out to Dallas he
said why no VR games because I'm gonna
be biased of course he said the Oculus
right I can't download this would be
crazy
what PlayStation game you picking next
huh there's only one actually uh
Valkyrie elysium's a PlayStation
I'm gonna go uh high on life
[Music]
I can't fight you I'm about to say B2
like I I can't I I can't fight you I
think that game's getting a bad rap I
think that game is way better than
whatever the Metacritic is
yeah I got I got you yeah I I think I
haven't played perfect it's not perfect
you know what it is it's it's tough to
do comment if you think about Justin
Roiland and like Rick and Morty like all
that stuff like all that stuff is is an
edited show like very tightly edited in
a game you gotta create gameplay and you
just so it might wear on you if you're
hearing all these jokes for like five
hours on end or whatever people that say
you can't make a game strictly off
comedy I agree combat it's hard gameplay
has to be somewhat there I haven't
played it yet but just off the comedy
itself makes me want to dive in I
actually want to stream it and it's just
like
I can't join curses so much
yeah you cannot play that for the kids
and and the message it gives on certain
things man
see I'm looking at it as an adult but as
a father yeah nah you can't play that
song
I was just streaming on my channel we
got it yeah we know who else okay who's
next
uh it's it's me then
um
Sonic
oh Sonic Frontier uh-huh I didn't play
it probably a I think this is a c oh
okay so and then I think it's got a
great foundation and it can be built on
really well but I think it was missing a
lot of elements that made Sonic song
oh
put it put it right next to it
yo yo Chris
they're touching tips
[Laughter]
don't cross the streets across the
street yo Chris uh high on life talks
too
not just a little head on your hip I
can't all right so we're voting on Sonic
right haven't played it everything that
I've heard is like great like that
caddock said like great foundation and
it's just certain Sonic isms is still in
there so I'm agree with c
oh so two Seas
over this I ain't fighting you I can't
fight you I'm not gonna waste anything
for this yeah I was gonna put it to be
but you know it is what it is let's do
naraka that's your next one I'm sure oh
yeah yeah all right
um I'm doing a taco Sonic is a dude
the rock of Blade point oh man that's
this is my baby
um I'm jumping out the window I'm going
hey it's the best Battle Royale you
think Battle Royal to me it has campaign
it has
um what you call Advance
I think people just haven't played it I
just think it's it's it's the number one
PC joint going in in in what you call it
any other region yeah the rocket play
point is a man they just dropped they
did a a a near automata collabor just
now and and I love how to translate it
to the console
um it's now on I mean on Xbox this year
yeah it's the first time it came but I'm
just saying like the the same the love
for it you don't really see it on the
console or the way you know they started
off strong I just still think that the
Game Pass thing is now helping it and
they just launched an Xbox One version
of it which surprised me just like this
one the rocket playpoint is is
ridiculous someone said uh no neo blade
uh Xenoblade no one on this panel no one
played it we was going to put you know
when we won it we was like nobody played
it and what we even talked about putting
it on here but we were literally all at
least one of us has played every one of
these guys we needed one person so we're
literally gonna put a game
that's the only reason
this year I finally gave up purchasing
games that I know I'm not even gonna
touch so it's just something all right
any detractors from no you know what
yeah yeah I'm gonna fight you on the on
the service game
[Laughter]
I do think it's probably more of a b
game but I can understand why people
would see it as an anchor
no doubt um solve it's your turn
the Callisto protocol oh
just
it's a
fight
[Music]
it's a c it's a c I think
it
the expectation of it being the
spiritual successor to dead space in the
end when you see the product that you
get hurts it because it's it's
definitely much more melee based there's
differences in how it feels it's not as
scary which I don't know if that was not
what they intended it's definitely not
as scary it's more of an action horror
game than it is a survival horror game
um obviously the technical hiccups
really put a a damper on how I feel
about it even now it's still not there
so it's a c because it has potential
Only The Dead Space remake could be the
Dead Space killer I think it's like a c
plus B minus like around there yeah um I
do think it could it had the potential
to be a b if it worked at launch because
I do think there was a game there but
the fact that it didn't work at launch I
felt like the combat felt clunky at a
lot of points
um I do think there's a great Foundation
there and I hope they get a chance to
make another one but as if as of
launched that game is a seat it is one
of the prettiest games I've ever seen
yeah
King did not play it so King gives you a
muppet mouth
all right
hey
[Music]
I think it's a b
solve
fruit of Japan
black and white great story
uh great combat and the moment this
thing gets an a if it does he gonna say
it's better than God
um everything is better than God it's
it's a b i I just kind of felt like the
combat yeah was it I still like it I
would have liked it to be an amazing
game where you gotta turn we gotta turn
like that was weird I used to talk about
this with Maddie Maddie hates it because
of the control yeah and I really
couldn't fight him on that because I
mastered the parody there's certain
moves you get that you get op right but
if you don't get that you're just still
trying to play and I'm with you King
that you know like the the samurai
Blackwater field and they're going in
the
background
yeah I got to use my last one because
um it's not my fault that people can't
turn around fast enough
so if you would be tough for check
through you want to be an a yeah because
um I'm not using my last video I got a
game in particular I want to use it I
thought that the game did everything
that it was supposed to do and the fact
that it launched the Game Pass
there you go you know I got I got a
reply
hey yo is anyone going to veto that I'm
not you wasted about it my first one
ain't nowhere in the hell that game is
good it's a strong beat
good I wanted you to do that so I could
put it right next to God of War
oh song with the couch the hot sauce you
got two in the tank you got two I got
two in the tanks too okay if the cake is
used up we get donuts cause I don't care
about nothing else you know what's funny
song I considered using my last veto I'm
so glad you got one I have one so two
two one okay okay well that's off you
said somebody said solve coming through
yes well that's enough
hey he's not really a master said it's a
hey
um all right let's go Pokemon
D oh okay let me vote let me fraudulent
vote
horrible graphics
I must say it's in the CD range it's one
of those
glitches yeah yeah performance even
Donald taku got D you know it but let's
just let's just go dude
where did Nintendo fans at I want to
know what they feel I mean I think a lot
of people feel like in terms of the
things they bring it's new akw got an A
wow that's what I'm saying a lot of
people really love what they know it
brings to it there's a lot of
performance stuff is like horrible
there's a lot of things that does good
it makes competitive Pokemon a lot
easier because you don't have to really
grind as much but the fact that that
game that game launched some of like one
of the worst launching games this year
like as far as how Metroid yo Nintendo
fans they say yeah
when emulated on PC all right your turn
oh let's see all right better okay
um oh let's have some fun let's go
let's go play tale requiem
hey Tia y'all this is classic I'd have
to say A2 yeah
I haven't played but I'll probably
concur hey this is a solo with a stone
bags
you can make an st argument too
graphical Fidelity but I'm gonna go a
I'm gonna go a I mean you could you you
could I could but anyway but you can't
there's only two last year games
so right hmm
hmm
let me get easy one Rainbow Six
extractions
unanimous continue you know it's a deal
with you we saw that for free day and
date for a game you'll be something
don't give nothing for free that joint
is dead bushes
we didn't put it in crossfire King oh
yeah you know what Crossfire Rivals same
thing
worse yeah yeah it'll be the first half
we'll be Crossing it's my turn yeah yes
uh Mario rabbits uh hey
okay
yeah I gotta defer to attic because he's
the one that played the most I would say
a yeah I'm not gonna fight I haven't
played I ain't fighting yeah I ain't
gonna fight hey excuse his egg okay
better than God of War
all right I'm picking
Dying Light tube oh
I think I think this this is a a b okay
the performance was hurting it from
being a a this is an a game as it stands
but when it launched it's it was a big
game maybe but we can't go about what it
is right now we gotta go about what it
did when it when it launched I mean at
that point you can you have to go back
and consistently change stuff cyberpunk
was different when it launched yeah yeah
okay yeah it's a it's a b it's a b
because of the performance stuff and
also they didn't really deliver on the
story stuff they were promising like
that that really didn't hit like it was
supposed to the whole thing where the
the factions that you pick and it didn't
really do it like it would translate
yeah yeah I think that's fair be and to
be honest with you it probably should be
a c but I do think the gameplay the the
uh you know the the movement of the game
I think that is so strong you can carry
the rest of the game I mean it'll be an
a game by the time they finish
supporting it because yeah 10 years
yeah Eva West
evil West
I'm gonna go
I wanted it to be an a
I really wanted but it's more that
classic 360 energy
you know frenetic what I think that's a
d I'm going to be
that game doesn't even deserve to be on
a b ring oh you can put that game with
midnight Sons Last of Us Part One why
you don't like it I'm curious I just I
didn't like I tried it for for like an
hour and I just dropped I just didn't
like the way I mean I could argue with
you guys if you feel like it's a beat
I'm just curious I was just kidding it's
just I just I don't know like it it hit
for me man yeah I don't I think I think
games like Dying Light two midnight Suns
last of us
I'm not counting.org this is the world
this is the world
so Eva West is a disappointment
disappointment I don't I think the most
I would ever give this game to see like
I just don't think we be can we because
I feel like I feel like you got the most
you got the most I feel sorry I feel
like a b is stating that the game was
great and A's amazing yeah you
definitely you definitely you definitely
able to hear you I'm definitely swaying
me a little bit I'm looking at it
through the lens of what it was always
supposed to be and that is a a a Xbox
360 ass Xbox 360 game and that's what it
is and I think it does it as well as any
like if you want to think about like the
the template for an Xbox 360 action game
this is it but the thing is are we being
in the story I love the fact that they
have this all this lore around this
vampire stuff that that existed way
before and and like the old west stuff
they incorporate it and they create a
story and a world that is very fun and
kind of it's it's not just surface level
they are like mostly going in Seas
across the boards that's fine because
yeah I don't yeah I don't like me you're
not all like me so that it stays I say c
yeah what are you saying B what is stop
saying because he got the Bulls out I
want to see it's a b it's a b King okay
B or C I'm gonna go with the chat c
b or c
no I said c it's neither out of the
highest I would give it is a c
I didn't play alone
from what up it's tough because I like
it but I I could see a little
shallowness in it
with the rail do you think okay let me
put it to you this way think about
anything like upgraded weapons right you
can do all that stuff you had to upgrade
tree like I said the story it's it's a
ridiculous story that works because they
they go all in on it I got I I got I got
I gotta ask you one question
um do you feel like Eva West is just as
good as dust box
putting that game in that category
you're saying that that game has the
same type of quality that you didn't see
something to me is saying that it's it's
really flawed like it's something really
oh we got a lot of things to see that
are really good but flawed
this is I mean it's like
let's see
ah this is tough
all right I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go see I'm gonna go see oh my
God I was gonna use my veto thank you
you know you know why I solved I'm just
gonna go by like you know when you play
something and then you can't wait to get
back to it yeah with midnight Suns and
all the other b games came I went back
to him so I couldn't wait I didn't go
back to evil West with that same Vigor
that I went back to grounded you know
midnight Suns as does Falls but I
couldn't wait to finish even pentiment I
went back to so it's like there is
something I don't I can't put my finger
on it that's not making me get back as
quick like I wanted to finish the other
game so for now that's what I'm sorry
guys and I love that game too but I
don't know who picked that one
no no I don't know who picked evil West
I did I was in there okay so it's all
it's your turn oh sorry
um
the ascent is Vampire Diaries uh vampire
um yeah so if you see a set that's
vampire survivors
what is what is next to a scent I can't
tell what that is that is uh Elysium
didn't play that
um tunic
tactics Reborn Final Fantasy 7 Crisis
Core iudin Chronicle Rising awful escape
and Doman
Chronicles Rising
our full escapers this year yep
we hold a check okay double check that
it could be wrong we got we gotta double
check that I could have sworn
that may have been chat double check on
all for this game because it may just
come out to other platforms when it was
Xbox or something first
the chat said last year yeah
we'll double check that you get off the
list so I didn't I didn't Chronicle
Rising okay
yeah he's right I obviously came out to
other platforms this year but it was out
last year yeah they're right okay cool
okay cool okay could you get our adult
uh chat sir you know they out here
promote when they they wears appreciate
you all right so
um it's a horizon yeah you did the
little joint I think
it's it's a c I think it's a it's a
great game lead up to what you know
iudon Chronicles are going to be but
okay
yeah it's a c I would actually say it's
one of the better games in the seat here
I would say that it is one of the better
games no doubt no doubt is everyone
agreeing to see yeah I'm not gonna fight
yeah okay
um
King
tunic B
yeah tunic is good I actually think
that's a name oh I actually think it's a
name and I would not fight you you're
right it's a name I actually think the
quality of that game is good I won't
fight you at all you know what he went
for B because he thought that was the
highest he could get for it Lydia Lydia
has to ask case out the a the A's are in
there for two they go hard for tuning
into a it could have been an S
um I think some people were turned off
by the combat
um
and just when you go back through it's
not
it it isn't you don't you don't have
those oh wow moments the way you had
like with a fez or something like that
and I think some people were turned off
by the fact that they expected Zelda
yeah and that's not what this game is
really
um okay it's a name No Doubt I'm let's
do Final Fantasy oh Crisis Core now I
haven't played it
um
but what I see
it's a solid b-a-ish maybe B plus a
minus yeah I think it rounds in that
yeah they gave it the uh the Final
Fantasy 7 remake touch upgraded yeah
everything
um I don't let's care for the PSP little
roulette mechanic but that's in there
and that's part of it so I'm not gonna
go harder but it they they the battle
system is revamped so this is the
closest Xbox fan is gonna get to this so
yeah yeah to the rebate yeah it's B it's
B
let's go Dolmen let's have some fun with
attic
um I'm gonna go see there's this thing
potential to be really great but still a
couple of flaws we really we played it
at Pax we loved it but
really really good foundation for a
great game
and defer to y'all didn't play yeah we
think it's a c okay
it's definitely I would say it's like
towards the I I do think it's
what it's better than straight oh and
it's and it's better than Gotham Knights
I do think Callisto protocol is better
than it and so is uh the uh eluding
right Rising I think it it's on the same
level
okay uh songs your turn
the Quarry oh Quarry
the
I'ma say hey whoa
whoa I think the Corey's the best game
they've made since until dawn
I'ma let y'all battle this out I'm about
because I did not play the score
this is between y'all y'all vetoing yeah
I'm gonna sit with my r r Lord and I'm
gonna say hey
oh wow the quarries at a yeah I could go
ahead and do that because I ain't
touching that
hey
it's just a great story you can play it
with other people you can play it online
so it's just I I think it's one of the
better games I'm sorry continue finish
finishing it's one of the better games
that's came out this year the quality's
there the story's good so we got this
over as dust Falls with the story yes
wow
it's just I feel like the Quarry is a
better quality as does fall okay if it
does Falls had the graphics that Corey
had I would say the Corey's better than
it but it does no way no way oh they
going in on the chat that's a good thing
you guys ain't in the you in the chat I
can't I would veto y'all I just didn't
play it I I can't
I like the sound of this game over yeah
I don't I don't like that bully bully
car gonna use this veto
hey let's get the hate move you into the
beat here sir I can't have you I can't
have you out here I'm fighting for for
shout out to Interior that is for you
during the night that's just for you I
can't have them over them y'all and I'm
frauding I'm I'm cold fraud and I'm
going with the chat my last veto oh
joking
is everyone out of Vetoes but me I got
one dogs got one I got one left one yeah
[Laughter]
what's your turn hmm
triangle strategy
oh
I'm I'm on a podcast
[Laughter]
she's like I'm trying to shattered you
suck all right so where you want it to
be called uh so
strategy bro
it's a name that's a yeah A2 that's it
that's what I'm saying look at flame s s
yeah
I would love rules so nice
so that a level is so dope
forbidden
everything thank God
it's triangle Quarry is better than
Ragnarok per of the Lords no per one no
per one Lord
let's and listen I didn't play The
Quarry
but I'm pretty sure it never got reused
assets all right so people in the chat
said I love taxes Camp I haven't played
triangle yet if you have a PC or a
switch that is a must play for a tactics
like game they said the A's is punking
the bees that that game and it's in its
genre now if you just if you just like
if we were doing just like tactics type
I almost put uh uh the dial for
Chronicles I should have but that was on
the four o'clock yeah
that's it okay
final joints I just went I just went it
was me
um uh Survivor yes vampires
how deep this game is when you go
further into the games the the unlocks
that you have this Secrets it is a very
very deep game I'm telling you don't be
don't be swayed by oh I just I don't
press any buttons I'm telling you right
now you're gonna fight my bro only
because together we can win we can win
and get him out of here with this this
right here he's got two we got one each
together we can win we have enough
this is tough because
but he right in this sense
no no let me tell you where he's right I
gotta shut up I haven't done the end
game so to speak right he's done so I
don't want to go hard and then I'll be
frauding and I didn't and then I end up
you know why it's an S because it's one
dude that fishes
I'm not feeling this people was at me
over the court being an a use your joint
I only got one I know I got I got one
too you should you you should hold on we
got look we got we got uh hold on a
second the angry therapist everything
it's an s
uh
it's an S it's an
sons of the year
I'm not filming it's a complete seat
here listen bro
if you call you got a seat to your game
you're either biased against games or
you haven't played enough of it stand
with me Carl I want to use my veto if
you use your feet I would ride with you
it's just that I'd be frauded
but we didn't do that I didn't do the
end game so if the end game was the most
amazing end game and I didn't play it
again
I'm telling you the game is an S no
clearly we have clearly yo um
you know when a game
consumes you every waking moment what is
it about this end game though like it's
not even about the end game it's it's
the game it's the game it's just the
moment
no no what is it it's it's
the game the game is it's simplistic
at the end of the day at the end of the
day I feel you guys the game plays fun
we vote stuff on a variety of
differences
if there's a got a story no because he
got a gameplay
let me hear this you know I don't really
care for too much you already know what
I did with with God of War God was a but
you know I I could have had it yeah DLC
for you but I don't I that s tier is
very reserved for the top tier games
it's only two games on this list that
consumed myself it's not Elder ring
level man
okay so attic it was special about Elder
ring tell me eldering it's the
exploration the graphics the world
design the Lord the presentation the
it's it's the ability to go in there and
just kind of the game you do what you
want to do and the game allows the
gameplay that's all that you literally
wanted
to play Middle Ground I use my veto
sinister
literally you you're you're trying to
get it
look how many people compared to the
people saying it's a CEO how many people
are saying a plus but I'm offering you
an a um
uh yes I played I got like seven eight
hours in the game that's not enough
straight up it ain't that's straight up
not enough if we do this but here's this
100 you ride with me we'll write this
too till tomorrow
no King does not have a voice
when you look at a game and you graded
by every aspect you mean to tell me
gameplay is gonna overshoot everything
else
hold up there's no story behind this guy
it doesn't happen there's no emergency
there's no Graphics behind it there's
literally the amount of pixels that is
on that screen slow down
I won't give them that way
addicts [ __ ] he's he needs a narrative
and I know why he's saying that he's
there is narrative behind this gate
I'm going to stay out I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna I'm gonna I'm sorry but you
can use yours y'all can use yours no
he's just gonna fix your mind
that's right
I've never seen him like this and sleep
well tonight knowing it's an ass
it's an s all right um could you please
um put vampire Survivor out there yeah
I'm not gonna fight I believe
so we don't got because technically a
second is representative
the ascent is
coming at me because I want to use the
Corey and a but people want to sit there
and just be okay with putting in an ass
wait who came at you for Quarry
no he know he got he got balls for me he
got balls for me only thing I held
strong on is where he at
all right all right whose turn is it
hold on let me read these stupid chats
we got bad super chats uh let me see
there we got a bunch hold on a second do
you need a JPEG file of the image that's
what you need for it no I don't know why
it didn't yeah so vampires the Latin
Spartan goes with the two pounds of the
chat vampire Survivor is a complete seat
here yeah let's take a Sit off because
it looked weird to having that set up
there just look weird
just kidding I don't want to see your
set he said the Lord's really loving
scent
we got the rubber knob five dollars hit
the like button to all all of this
fraudulent voting
then we have uh sit duck remember for 29
sure duck sorry sir duck remember for 29
months
I'm gonna bring the king energy since I
can't get past first level where price
survivors is a deep
which has Survivor ain't no Double
Dragon Nostalgia bait that is true love
Double Dragon when you play it again
ain't that great
then we have let me see that again
throwing a taco two dollars Super Chat
there's Lord vampire survivors
blow up their jeans to this game yeah I
would totally appreciate if we come
together and defeat big bad song
you don't trust me when I tell you this
everybody you spoke to told you what
this is but here's the thing though I
didn't feel that way when I yeah
one of the best games ever made he was
born in a time where the pixels but we
acted like hey I feel you I feel you but
we acted like a is disrespect like I'm
trying to give it to me disrespectful to
vampire Hunters
when I played it I was like first of all
it looked not good yeah then I threw it
on and I'm like oh okay they keep going
and going then all the stuff start
coming on the screen like yo this is
crazy then when I had fun was when I
said okay I got to go got the loop go
pick the other character now I got the
wall now I got the Bibles going around
yeah what you know what I'm saying and
it's the survival aspect of it and it's
good but I wasn't like this is the
greatest thing I've ever played in the
history of games
like it's it's generation like like
nothing before I feel like the only time
you would give an S break something is
if it's like one of the best yeah like
like you gotta do something that I've
never really wanted you to talk about
just core gameplay
a video game which you play
anything together
what is the game the gameplay is fun and
it's addicting and I give you that but
what is it doing different that we've
never seen before us take what it does
it was every everybody who's been
playing top tier graphic games forever
all of a sudden through on this tiny
little game
long enough he wants to breathe beat it
down because it's ugly games
but I did I said yo I respect it it's a
good game it's that Elder ring level
it's a good a but you guys are like no
it's got it
use your veto don't worry about his no
but but no call no three times that he
thinks this is a good game
I I need to know what's the revolution
why are you in his Visa
let me ask you something is is Miss
Pac-Man an s-tier game
[Music]
when vampire Hunter Survivor Lord there
was nothing like this doing this oh man
now bro
listen look at the Simplicity of it tell
me what Simplicity but tell me what is
it about the gameplay specifically
please explain to me when you get past a
certain point all the law that addict
says isn't there it's there it's there
so tell me tell me explain it so explain
to me the lore no I'm just I'm not
trying to be funny I'm really trying to
learn because I didn't get to that part
so just help me with that that's the
part I'm with addict I need to know what
that law is what is it that it's doing
be specific so I could help me because
if you can't then I'm gonna go back to
at it because I'm gonna be like it's a
great a game until you tell me what this
law is that's so amazing or what it is
that's doing so this that's right game
is saying this is one of the best games
ever made it is it kind of is
I'm sorry the gameplay Loop is the
reason games like Hades do well it's a
great game pay Loop but it but yeah
that's where it is y'all say it is but
like why is a disrespectful I want to
know chat like why is a like the
horrible thing to give it like it is not
disrespectful me disrespecting God of
War is something totally different yeah
right that that like to me if you would
have said like if this was the year when
Hades came out song I would have backed
off I'd have been like yo we got the law
we got Hades we got the Greek gods we
got the thing we got a roguelite we got
a thing you know what I'm saying like I
I'm like this is great but like never
genre before like whatever all I'm
saying
that's the reason I give triangle
strategy next because I love the game
gameplay is amazing
but just explain that point if y'all can
win me over that if not I'm gonna go hey
I gotta win me over I gotta win me over
with this sorry I'm sorry I can't help
you on this I wish I could have my my
videos
bro I need to help me help me you know
you know what you know besides burning
up another game that looks like it and I
don't want to hear just because it is
because it is
in between things like that's right um I
play the game I don't care that 30
million people played that's bad I want
to know why
it's it's
how I judge games is how I'm consumed by
them right yeah right exactly why are
you consumed by it
the gameplay
we'll have your have you really there
saying all right one more time one more
time how many times have we what Hades
did the exact same thing gave you a
gameplay so your thing is the addictive
nature of it that you can't put it down
to this game tells you how great the
game is
because that's right great that's the
problem for me I'm the one that voted in
an S let me right to be honest like no
fifth King got no veto so like really
yeah this is saying that s so we can't
really convince him an a right yeah so
listen you can say whatever you can do
whatever with your veto it's fine what
I'm saying is for me the game is an S
and it's an S is because
games that consume you and you you all
didn't even understand why I was playing
eldering
Madden Madden would win if addiction
matter
NBA 2K got that that addiction people
spending yeah that's it for somebody's
on this panel that I want to say okay
right so right now on this panel I chose
to put vampire Survivor I'm gonna tell
you
but the story the story is so the story
is essentially all of these characters
are from one family right okay right it
is kind of like the Belmont family type
thing characters exactly and and and so
it's nonsensical this is a regular type
of it's nonsensical fit okay this this
seems
okay and it's just them fighting off the
hordes of this evil monster because
remember there are bosses right
the unlocks you continue to get
throughout the game so it that's what
will you tell me there's no lore there's
nothing you're just doing it for no
reason
it's in there whether you care about it
or not or whether it like I said it's
not it's very Dracula okay so tell me
what's the tell me the lore of Elder
Rick tell me what it is we've been here
I've told you this multiple times you
haven't told me it's it's about the
Rings it's about the Rings being broke
and with those Rings breaking no one
could truly die they're stuck between
the middle of death in life and it's
about restoring the Rings so they can
actually die what now soft
did you have to find that law or did it
happen organically in gameplay but
there's more than just this I'm just I
own a ring okay hold up
[Applause]
how's that gameplay they're talking
about and everything else right and
that's why it's an S if you care to find
it and that's fine I agree to your game
but here's the thing it has those other
features that make it that s tier
I just think you you taking you saying
that a game a game now a game for it to
be a fully fledged game has to Encompass
all of those different things now for it
to be considered on that level it's not
being it doesn't make any sense to me it
doesn't put anything hey it's a
fantastic game that's the part I'm
leading with like a is fantastic no I'm
not saying it's not fantastic that's
what I'm saying is that all I'm saying
you're telling me what you're trying to
tell me is it the game
what you're trying to tell me that if it
does not Encompass all of these other
things that are relatively new to gaming
period if you think about it we've been
around 40 years okay
you're telling me that it doesn't
Encompass each and every one of those
aspects of what a game can be it can't
be up there here's the thing
no way I can't agree with you if we were
if we were pairing these under the
respective genres that would be in you
could have that mindset but we're
comparing these on all the games that
came out in 2023 correct all right if
you are on that s tier you got to do
everything in the industry
but I have to address this because I
think this is also a factor
for those who are saying s
would we be saying this as over 40. if
it wasn't an XBox exclusive game
yeah that doesn't what I'm talking about
to the chat to the chat
for everybody
played the game I'm getting past okay
but you but you different
bro it's on phones now wow right did it
just drop down or is it everything yeah
so how are you gonna be 30 minutes of
trying to have them explain to you and
we still ain't did these videos
because he know he knows in his heart of
hearts what we're talking about
the things all the things that you're
mentioning
I understand I actually agree with both
of y'all
who is it a better job explaining
whether or not that game deserves to be
an A or have they did a better job
explaining why it deserves being asked I
think you've done a better job
explaining why so then let's let's veto
and get on with the show
it's a unique new genre of game two
system power Dynamic is extremely
satisfying three
actual lore and story it hits different
the finale is amazing yeah definitely I
haven't ended wait there's a fanatically
you die automatic no no see oh I didn't
know I'm asking I'm asking I don't know
see okay tell me educate me I know you
you like because I'm you know what it's
all in there but I'm not of the argument
that if game has no end no it's not
worthy of being here like I'm not saying
I just didn't know this town
argument this is like I'm excited now
what tell me
yo listen I really had a hard start
before all right finish it today
we did it again we didn't get it six
hours ago she can't explain explain
quick no yeah no because it's a spoilers
don't beat me down this birthday boy is
on oh he doesn't took a pre-workout he
out of control I just dropped a major
ball you know because they don't got no
explanation for it that's why I hesitate
to say it
I haven't ended it and as I don't have
any vetoes okay
the game does have an end and that dude
that comes to kill you after 30 minutes
can be killed yeah gravel story to be
great
I'm staying out of here I don't have
enough and for this I'm just torn so I'm
gonna stay I don't I can't vote against
it yeah
bro I wanted to but it's just like
there's not enough it's inconclusive and
if it's inconclusive for me then it's by
Logic I have to stay out I have to stop
I feel like by that lot you wanted to
corrupt them
my emotions my heart
wants to go without it my heart was to
go with addicts
no but by Logic is inconclusive and when
my when I don't have all the information
okay hold up then let me ask you this
no bro hold up what was your reasoning
to veto in the Quarry from A to B I told
you I was still hating no leave it I was
pure hating that was no logic
emotional
I don't hate vampire enough for this
thank you
but you don't the core you just love
yeah I love that stuff
all right all right alert on me
I got what y'all want all right Elysium
is a d because I think I'm the only one
that played that and okay where are we
gonna put tactics Reborn
I think it's a b yeah
put this scent up to the F now we don't
like the way that looks and send it up
there
where's the tactics reborn where yeah b
b yeah we ain't gonna fight all right
cool all right cool we good everything's
good we're good
do you want it an a no
which one
the the original is an A but it it's
just it's just re-skinned with voice
it's fine we all good so that there it
is
nonsense up here rubber knob two dollars
what gameplay oh do you what what
gameplay do you do all you do is run
around here
we got Lucius Augustus two dollars as a
Nintendo endure gameplay trumps
everything thank you quanticus uh uh
Spartan ghost two problems with that
there's a better pixel there's better
picture games in that mid game
I really like you yeah
RDJ 2010 vampire Survivor spawned a ton
of copycats yes it did look at this one
called hentai survivors
then we got a temper twenty ten dollars
which have both as Cheer games have lore
you have to find by playing and explore
exploring
gonna talk I read this one the Donna
Taco one already uh RDJ two lots which I
addict learned the law from YouTube not
the gay
you're ridiculous there we go like this
cute dude you're five dollars to put
that Nintendo games outside of Zelda
never have great stories or lore they
are still some of the best games ever
made
I'd actually disagree with that but
continue man did go big dick his DLC is
not permitted to be higher than a beat
you uh I love the seven hour debate
podcast over one game bro
you know why I apologize I apologize
because for some reason I got into my
feeling I've never seen resolved like
that feelings I got into my feelings
attract to yomi because if I had saved
all of them there'd be no discussion
yeah
whoever made that Super Chat just put it
back in the chat into an atsall yeah
five dollars from Domino's Super Mario
Odyssey is an S tier and that's barely
any Story Stop the cap addict
um no that that's an A2 all right buddy
yeah attic can you run back because I'm
not in I'm not in the YouTube
let's get up out of here while we before
we run it back just get the pole Wi-Fi
there's no pull because we not coming
back to next year
yeah yeah look we made it so yeah thank
you real quick we missed um
put the clap to the air yo again only
IOP every time 909 said we missed eight
I'm sorry we were in the middle of the
argument and I forgot to copy paste
I got a two dollars picture from uh Lord
Metro I will take gameplay over anything
else every time and we also have uh it
was hold on again miss mine too Tom 909
uh these debates are why I love IOP
every Christmas thinking about it thank
you that was fun we turned the simplest
thing into something
with the five dollar Super Chat uh
Vampire Diaries was an a for the first
20 minutes or 20 hours if you gave me an
S when you realize how deep it actually
goes okay
cool cool yeah yeah sure look y'all
another year man thank you realm thank
you Chad thank you guests thank you Kai
everybody man that's a fantastic some of
the Lords of gaming.net South to
everybody that pulled up developers
console makers man for everybody that
debates even when you came in here to
disagree you came ahead and I had fun we
made you laugh we made you laugh you
know and a lot of community you know we
got one of the best communities in the
in the world
um very thankful our Ascension is still
going we got a lot more to do we got
more fun things planned but I just want
to say thank you man it's been a
phenomenal yeah I mean I do need the
rest you know what I mean yeah we all
need we've been we've been burnt out
we've been birthed out and the last
thing we want to do is let that bleed
out into the show so we wanted to you
know kind of do the shout out to attic
man first let's give Atticus flowers
because not only that injected so much
fun into the podcast segments like this
things that we normally do even when we
do Crown your lord the graphic like we
would not be here without our brother
like our brother takes us to the next
level again he birthed I hope he
reminded me back in the day when I I got
I thought I was going to go to court I
had a documents he was like now that's
it I said I ain't loyal podcast and and
this is what I said it and I was like oh
so I would have lost the question
now but forget all that that's about bro
you know we we friends for real all of
us you know what I'm saying we hang out
for real and I love what we do you know
what I'm saying so this was an st
episode for me as I said we had fun we
had our interview we had offices you
know what's funny right like I almost
snuck in Game Pass being one of those
times
just
just to waste all of them
you're losing gonna waste my veto since
I was going straight for God of War no
doubt so I want to thank you brother you
know the balance you bring you know the
intelligent you've really Rose this year
I felt like you really took it to the
next level you had some of the the best
quotables some of the best uh passionate
subjects even when it gets controversial
Not Afraid and you're my balance to
control them Savages I miss when you're
not here you know what I'm saying so
salute to you thank you I don't even
know what to say brother like we've come
so far me and you you know what I'm
saying we've come so far I love you we
do things together like back in the day
you know what I'm saying this podcast
has literally taking all friendship back
to the next level
um we wouldn't be here without you you
are the face you you put this thing on
you got it on your own for real you know
what I'm saying like it's on my chest
facts you know what I'm saying yeah
and let me tell you right now like when
you are not here that chat be like bro
it's like
where's the Jackson 5 at you know what
I'm saying like nah but you you are
literally I've always told you you're
literally the funniest person I know but
when you need to be real and you need to
do man talk you need people get to see
it you know what I'm saying so salute to
you man like again we would not be where
we were without you you know what I'm
saying you took us to the next level and
again like I said attic I've already
given you flowers but I'm giving you
again happy born day you know what I'm
saying I'm so proud of you you know what
I'm saying your growth has been
tremendous you know you take the
feedback you take the criticism and you
come back straight and then you take us
to the next level you know and you're a
loyal dude you're a loyal dude people
don't say that enough about you you
really be in the trenches with us and we
had them long conversations late at
night so I love you I love y'all man
y'all my brothers another year you know
what I mean and thank you everybody you
know they always send us love and send
me love you know doing a hosting show is
not easy sometimes with a strong
personalities that I got to deal with
you know what I said all the things the
moving Parts but um I love to do it and
that's why I'll stay up two three in the
morning just thinking about things to
add to the show and commentary and you
know we love what we do so that's all I
got enough good stuff but I'm gonna let
y'all get y'all bars off addict thank
you to the realm you you up what you
want to say to the realm for the last
one in 2022. yeah so you know pretty
much voicing a lot of the stuff that Cog
said you know we we come together it's
because we generally love this gaming
thing we love each other you know we uh
we we're very vocal about opinions and
uh I think that's normally you couldn't
get this many high tension people in a
room without beef being started
conversations but you know we got love
for each other so we don't let it get
that far yeah except for them voting
but you know snitching
next year we we will uh be coming twice
as hard I am going to probably get what
time oh my god with uh solve sometime in
the next couple weeks to re revamp the
memberships and the patreons uh we're
gonna try to incorporate everything we
do like r r addict show iron lore's
podcast because it's all on this channel
so we're gonna try to like give you guys
a little bit more with all those shows
and I just wanted them
uh so you appreciate everyone coming
through you know hit the like button
though man like hit that subscribe for
sure I kind of when I
was asking the lawyers did they want to
because eventually was gonna do like a
community thing we're gonna bring people
on tell about but I was like you know
what after me and King did our phase
four thing I was like that was fun and I
was like and I was just being King yeah
I can't imagine bringing the fun back
yeah I'll be bringing the fun back even
the stream yesterday that was fun like
bring the fun back absolutely and it's
just like you know I never thought we
would argue about the game we did argue
about but it was so fun that was crazy
song like that I was scared I was like
so I was like that was my fault because
I didn't I didn't hold on
because you know what I forgot I you
know what now I didn't even forget I
assumed you would ride with us Cog no
problem because of the OG
so you you so like to be fair to be
honest you knew I was gonna be nice no I
knew I knew that the center would be you
I was like Cochran just go he's like I
ain't playing enough everybody's talking
about this game everybody loves this
game I just told you Chris ray gun is is
so I'm just like nah he's good he's good
he's good then they're almost done
for a second there I feel I felt the I
felt the Seesaw coming back yeah I was
about to press the a button again I was
like it was almost where I could grab it
you're on the right side of History
don't worry about it
no doubt it of course Lord King man
wow
um this has been a crazy year personally
for myself it's been a nuts yeah
um and without this therapeutic stuff
every Sunday yeah we did uh I don't even
know how I can got out of it um and you
know to have you guys to talk to when
things is crazy we all want to share all
of us have something crazy this year
huge personal level all of us it's a
huge thing for me
um
to to look over at my brothers to do
something that we love to talk about
stuff that we love right and actually
share that love with everybody that
Tunes in
it's it's amazement I'm an utter
amazement I'm in utter amazement of how
hard Cog Works he makes me work harder
whatever I can do like you know
sometimes you don't have the skills of
one person right
but if you don't have the skills of that
person what you do is everything else
that you can do to help even something
out to pull away the load from an
individual because you know it's very
easy to tuck your hands in your pockets
grab a bag
grab a bag and pull your weight
um and everybody here what y'all see is
is funny because you know Cog said oh
when I'm not here that uh you know the
chat goes nuts
when he's not here
the podcast is not moving right when
attic is not here the podcast is not
moving right with solve is not here the
podcast is not moving right it takes all
four lions in order to form this
situation so it's it's it's it's not a a
oh Michael Jackson
nah that's just not it
is one unit no doubt all right so it is
nobody can come in and say hey man we
can give you a solo deal that's not it
from from this whole mission statement I
want us all to get that bag
so I would never take a bag if everybody
didn't get this the same price back
right so shout out to valari I'm very
proud of this pillow yes I'm very proud
of this pillow because when I send a
link out to people
I'm proud of it I'm proud of everything
I'm proud of addict coming to New York
I'm proud of us going to the studio to
see stuff I'm proud of stuff that we do
I'm proud of what's Happening next year
January oh yeah we got something that's
happening in January I'm proud of these
things because I'm doing it with my
family facts
I love you guys at death no doubt and um
if I don't say it enough uh it's because
maybe I'm sleeping
oh I just want to say the Attic
I sat there real hard and thought of
something that me and you can do
together yeah and I
said we're gonna do a show together
because I think me and you are Tango in
cash Starsky and Hutch Batman and Robin
whatever you want to want to put it I
think me and you really have a wife
Ebony and Ivory
all in all with the Lord is going to be
hella successful and hella funny
because of the energy and the outside of
the box thinking that you do
and um and I'm so happy that this
Tuesday is your last show too just so
the chat now yeah this Tuesday Avatar me
and him and we're gonna have such a good
time no doubt but I just wanted to tell
you that man I do really appreciate
everything that you do all right you
know solve I love the hell up yeah let
you get your bars off I didn't I forgot
you I need a week before I I forgive
solve at this point
2022 episode what can I say that you
haven't said already I always feel like
you know I'm the one who's not able to
be available to be more of a face you
know be on more shows and stuff like
that you know and it's I don't see that
really changing that's just the nature
of my life right so when I'm when I'm
able to be here on a Sunday like you
know I want to make sure that that
that I you know that I feel like I'm
contributing and I feel like like I'm
really part of this team but sometimes I
feel of my own accord not my not because
of my brothers but for me I'm like I'm
not I'm not as deserving of the
accolades that we get as a group
individually just because I'm just I
don't feel like I'm around enough so
thankfully I could do you know I can do
the behind the scenes money stuff and
you know make sure that we have our our
plane tickets and our way you know when
we travel and stuff like that we write
when we go to the city yeah and so you
know things like that you know I'm
grateful I can do that but I mean I
would love to be here more because you
guys are really like you really you're
killing it you know King we always knew
he was going to continue to find his
Lane and obviously with the boxing stuff
and the RNR like you said him and attic
that just this is perfect mixture with
those two right and cogley what can I
say brother like you the hardest working
dude in the industry like you got
multiple shows you got a very a
demanding job and AJ I gotta say brother
like bro it you bro you are so hell-bent
on us being successful yes this man will
text me in the middle of the night he
will call me when he has an idea
sometimes I can't answer I'm in the
middle of a meeting or whatever what the
case may be but he's always thinking of
what's next what's next I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this because I'm gonna
if he needs if he needs money for
something hey I found this thing that
can promote us here could brought us
there he's always thinking about how
we're gonna grow and this behind the
scenes stuff with the overlays setting
all this stuff up this is all stuff that
us old man for whatever we're not good
at we're not cool people in good today
we're in good at work
I I'm just
I'm going to be happiest the day the bag
is real and we can look at you and be
like yo brother don't worry about
nothing else you're good good you're
good and I can't wait for that day that
that's that's the most happy and
exciting and I'll be equally excited for
all my brothers as well you're my my old
brothers
but to see how much you you want this
and how badly you want this to be just
the life for all of us it's inspiring
man so again thank you to all of y'all
for bringing me on this ride and thank
you to guys in the chat I mean again
thank you look like we're coming up on
14 000 people who want to listen to us
on a weekly basis and people who just
love this community
um you guys are very special and no
doubt this doesn't happen without you
guys so blessings to everybody happy New
Year merry Christmas if you celebrate
that feel it at that yes I think I can
forget the chat next week
I got them I got them I was on a second
I better not hear next year that Zelda
can't be asked here as it didn't do
anything new
and you know what's funny
I've never remotely said that breath of
the wild is an S2 yeah he that's he's
been on that square
unless unless they give attic back his
classic Zelda yeah
remember 15 but salute Lords I
appreciate everything you four do in the
space the community is amazing as well
thank you thank you brother
David Crossing remember for seven months
Lord bronze you guys make my Sunday
every week much love for 2023 fellas
happy holidays to the IOP family to you
as well brother hello
then we got ham from TSW gambing ham
Solo in the building five dollar super
chat Merry Christmas y'all imma keep
working hard to see you on La shout out
to him for his latest yeah we're gonna
be there
shout out to hanford's latest interview
we're bringing up yeah with cells yeah
if y'all don't know cell cells is a a
Halo streamer she's out there she's
always putting up a compilation Brooklyn
yeah not the BK in the building he's
spotlighting people that are up and
coming so that was fantastic yeah and
we're gonna work like I said I just been
slow with the guesting but because I got
a respect and not overwhelm myself but
yeah and ham I know I owe you too yeah
we will work no worries just be patient
brother it'll happen no doubt are we
good we caught up enjoy your 2022 happy
holidays all that good stuff we will be
back in the New Year the first Sunday of
the New Year yes and then we will be
back so everybody look enjoy will your
body here less anybody got anything else
thank you
[Music]
super chanter nah Donald Taco damn you
five dollars breath of the wild is the
greatest game of the last 10 years and
tears of the Kingdom will Top it
significantly stand down at it that was
messy see you later next year
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]